and the next morning she was like
totally zered out and completely normal
meaning no suicidality meaning no
depression no nothing I mean she looked
like any person walking the street
totally normal and that was in 24
[Music]
hours Dr Williams good to see you sir
yeah thanks man thanks for having me and
I thought we would start with a personal
story not your personal story but a
story of dearra Leeman yeah could you
tell us who this person is how it fits
into your story but let's begin with
just a description of deardra yeah
absolutely so deardra is I think maybe
in her 50s 60s female in Bay Area has
suffered from bipolar disorder
much of her
life and you know pretty
successfully treated for the Mania side
of things over the years had a
psychiatrist taking care of that part in
Moren and happened to slip into this
pretty severe depressive episode a
couple of years back this it's
been maybe like four or five years now
her psychiatrist had actually gone to
see a talk that I gave at this mood
disorders day like the year before we
were talking this really early on when
we were you know working on a rapid
acting neuros stimulation approach and
the psychiatrist had heard the talk and
then her patient kind of fell into this
really bad suicidal depression and so
she reached out to me to treat her and I
got on the phone I'll never forget it
was like a Wednesday and I I got on the
phone with her psychiatrist and she was
telling me where she like
symptomatically how bad off she was and
I was like I don't think we can treat
her outpatient she's like way too ill I
think she needs to go in the impatient
hospital and you know gave her some
information on how to do that I see her
the next morning and and she's in really
bad shape what does that mean does that
mean like she's like how did that show
up yeah when people are at the level
where they like kind of definitively
need to go into the hospital they're not
really totally communicative anymore and
they've got some cognitive issues
sometimes and so in in her case you know
she couldn't look you in the eyes you
look at the ground and she was doing
this rocking thing mhm which you can see
in pretty severe depression Catatonia
overlap symptoms you know I mean she's
like at the kind of the very end of the
spectrum one of the highest severity
patients we've ever treated a score of
50 on the modus out of 60 like very very
severe right and just rocking and not
really talking and and husbands were
counting everything and she had bipolar
one so she was hypomanic I think or
manic like two weeks before and then
dropped into this very very severe
depression so it was her daughter and
the husband they're sitting in the room
with me and I'm they want me to treat
her and I say listen like it's Friday we
go Monday to Friday you have to find a
way basically to keep her well from now
until Monday and that means and by well
you mean safe like preventing self yeah
yeah exactly keep her not having a
suicide attempt basically from now until
Monday she's very suicidal and you know
and I said you're going to have to like
take every knife I mean I don't think
any guns but gun chemical like scissors
everything out of the house the whole
all of it has to go and you guys have to
be on like a 24-hour like you know watch
until Monday Monday morning rolls around
and we bring her in and the craziest
thing we had like a repair on the motor
threshold coil which is the coil you
used to kind of get calibrated on the
intensity and it shorted out the device
and blew the capacitor Bank up on the on
the first stimulator blew your flex
capacitor yeah yeah at like 700 a.m. and
I mean you can't imagine how stressful
that was so we had a second machine and
I'll tell you about this later but we
were running this like you know trait
hypnotizability modulation study and it
was over at the scanner so pretty far
away and this thing weigh like 100 lb so
so I had to send my team over there run
over there and grab it bring it over and
luckily we were able to kind of get her
going and treat her with the second
machine and I mean she was she was in
really really bad shape that morning and
by 5:00 that afternoon she was basically
normal and the next morning she was like
totally zered out and completely normal
meaning no suicidality meaning no
depression no nothing I mean she looked
like any person walking the street like
totally normal and that was in 24 hours
and we've seen this with with bipolar
patients quicker right it'll happen
really quick for like a bipolar one
patient you can get it done in sometimes
in a day just for Clarity by get it done
and don't worry people listening we're
going to Define terms and get into all
this but you're talking about
accelerated TMS yeah we're talking about
accelerated TMS so we you know our rapid
acting neuros stimulation approach we're
able to get people out of these states
and into normal mood and in short
periods of time generally like 2.6 days
on average for major depression patients
but it's quicker with bipolar we've seen
especially with bipolar 1 patients so
she was totally out of it in in 24 hours
that was like right around July 4th or
something and so the whole team left I
guess we'll talk about maybe talk about
caffeine later too so so my wife and I
are like big Phil's Coffee fans and so I
I'll never forget this either so we go
down to the Phil's Coffee in Pao Alto
after I saw them I'll never forget it
Clark Leman her husband also went to
Phils didn't know I was going to be
there and I I look over and this guy's
just kind of staring at me and I was
like hey how are you good to see you
again I like just saw that guy like 10
minutes ago and he's like I still don't
understand what happened you know and it
and it it makes sense right like to take
somebody from the worst you've ever seen
them mood-wise to like normal in such a
short period of time was remarkable for
him and after that period they actually
went out and really were helpful with a
lot of the philanthropy that led to all
the trials being funded and ultimately
you know the clearance and and Clark and
durra really were Advocates and have
continued to be advocates for for this
to kind of get it out into the world it
was totally based off of of that
experience of him feeling helpless you
know and going from that to to feeling
like it was all solved and I think she
went maybe a year completely
asymptomatic ended up needing to get
retreated again at some point but gets
like these little touch-ups here and
there and is able to stay well ongoing
and depression you know as they tell me
depression is not her problem anymore
she's a great kind of illustrative case
of what this can do and I I think what
the what the promise of it can be so
what I'd love to talk about next
is not necessarily direct mechanism of
action but I'd love to hear you just
just
explain a snippet that I pulled from
your conversation with Andrew huberman
yeah which was a very good conversation
specifically it was about and I'm not
going to use the right terminology here
so bear with me as a lay person but the
sequencing or abnormal pathological
sequencing of
activating activation or activity in
different parts of the brain so I don't
know if it's the interior singulate yep
I think you know what I'm alluding to
here would you mind just explaining that
because it was it was something that I
had never been exposed to and I found it
deeply fascinating and I'll just also
mention this context for people who are
listening to this that part of what is
deeply interesting to me about a number
of the different tools and modalities
that you explore in depth is not just
the speed of action but the durability
of effect yep super potent combination
and very un unusual from what I can tell
combination of things all right so as
far as the sequence of activation goes
could you explain what I'm referring to
we published a paper in the proceedings
of National Academy of
Science guess it's been about 6 months
ago now one of the former research track
resident postdocs in the psychiatric
program at Stanford hmra who's now
Junior faculty was working with Carl
dith and I during that training phase
and Onish had this interest in a
specific way of looking at brain Imaging
particularly this type of brain Imaging
called resting state functional
connectivity MRI and so resting state
functional connectivity MRI has been
around for a long time the resting state
part of it is basically tell a person
sit in the scan the MRI scanner and let
their mind wander so that's kind of the
resting state or the default mode
however you want to think about it and
functional connectivity what that means
is it it's the brain regions that have
blood flow that is time locked with each
other right and so essentially these
connected brain networks the blood flow
will go up or go down in those areas in
a time lock fashion and blood flow is
really time like you just mean at the
same time correlating yeah exactly yeah
and so why blood flow blood flow is is a
surrogate of electrical activity it's
hard to see electrical activity kind of
deep in the brain you know people see it
at the surface with eg but with IM I you
use the blood flow as like a surrogate
of the electrical activity and it makes
sense if you're you know using glucose
in a brain region because you're using
that Network then you need to have
cerebral Auto regulations so the blood
um vessels increase and they dilate more
blood goes into that area so it's just
like a response to to increased activity
and so you have these increases in blood
flow that are supposed to represent
electrical activity that are in
different separate nodes no in the brain
and they come on roughly at the same
time and we've known that for a while
Anish got very interested in this idea
that the timing of the blood flow is
temporally offset between these nodes so
slightly that people ignored it for a
long time but he was able through using
various math able to show that there's a
slight offset of the timing such that
one brain region slightly comes on
before the other and that's interesting
because that infers some level of
causality right so instead of the whole
network coming on at the same time maybe
it's just one area and it's signaling
the whole network on you know and it's
so quick that you see it as all like
this but really it's more like this
right if that makes sense like it's
coming on all at the same time but from
this network node kind of turning this
one on turning that one on or something
right like the lead Domino matters yeah
that's that's right the lead Domino
exactly so in the case of mood it looks
like the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex
the area that's involved in
control precedes slightly the singulate
cortex in our normal healthy control
population essentially nearly everybody
had that directionality in the depressed
cohort 70% of them had it flipped right
where the singulate was temporally in
front of the dors lateral but not
everybody and if you just had that
information then you wouldn't know what
to make of that like why why is it some
people and not others but what was
interesting is when he looked at the
folks that had it versus the ones that
didn't the ones that had it were the
ones that were responsive to our kind of
we'll talk about you know what saane is
and and the rapid acting Nur stimulation
approach in detail I guess later but
that you know the folks that responded
to Saint responded to this rapid acting
TMS approach were the ones that that had
the biomarker and the ones that had no
chance
did not have the biomarker and looked
like a normal healthy control and the
signal on the post scan flipped to look
normal and the folks that responded had
the biomarker and and then their brain
changed after and so the postscan looked
just like the pre-scan on the folks that
didn't clinically change in the normal
healthy controls we see this sort of
test all the time in medicine 10 people
come into the primary care doctor's
office with blurry Vision urinating a
lot drinking a lot
headache a lot of those folks probably
have diabetes but not all of them some
of them have you know migraine headache
and need glasses and you know some other
things and it looks like a diabetes
presentation but when you go and do the
blood sugar the blood sugar is normal
and in the folks that have elevated
blood sugar that look like they have
diabetes you go and you give them a
diabetic medicine and then it normalizes
so the blood sugar after looks like the
blood sugar of a normal healthy and
looks like the blood sugar of somebody
that symptomatically presented but
didn't have diabetes and so it was nice
to see this and we're replicating this
now we have money from the National
Institutes of Health to do that but this
idea that we're able to you know have a
test that would change and the same
thing that signals that there's an
abnormality is the thing that changes
later and that's more rare in Psychiatry
right to be able to have all of that
line up so we're pretty excited about
that and hope to see it it does
replicate in the larger population of
patients but as a conceptual idea it's
an important conceptual idea this
general idea of being able to use
neuroimaging or whatever it is eg
whatever it is to type different people
that are presenting with similar
symptoms and be able to say okay you're
going to respond to this and and not
this or vice versa and I think that's
part of what we need for Psychiatry
right because people spend just so much
time in their lives trying to find the
answer and we don't really have any
tests trial and error yeah it's a lot of
trial and error it's like pharmaceutical
ready fire aim Y in a sense and this
this raises I guess just a meta
observation SL question perhaps you
could just discuss this briefly which is
it seems to me like there have been and
this is part of the impetus for us
having this conversation part of the
impetus for me in the last let's call it
half year paying a lot of attention to
accelerated TMS which is there have been
these dominant paradigms in certain
types of let's call it psychiatric
treatments for things like depression
treatment resistant depression and it
seems like a very dominant Paradigm for
period of perhaps several decades has
been the chemical imbalance theory of of
psychiatric disorders so you have a
serotonin issue therefore we're going to
treat it in these following ways you
have such and such an issue sure we're g
going to give you snris and then like
you said it's a lot of trial and error
to figure out what works and even if
something works it may often only work
for a period of time it seems to me and
I want you to absolutely fact check and
correct everything that I'm saying but
that part of the reason that the
research you're doing and that others
are engaging in is so fascinating is
that it presents an alternative
Paradigm through which you could look at
certain disorders right like oh wait a
second well maybe this person's car when
you turn the ignition is just tripping
things in the wrong order yeah and if
that's causal we could try to address
that and then maybe that addresses what
we might have otherwise perceived as a
chemical disorder I have a lot of
follow-up questions but is that a
helpful way to think about this or what
would you add to that I would argue like
three eras in Psychiatry you know what
friends of mine have called Psychiatry
1.0 2.0 3.0 and you know the first era
was this era in and around Freud and
this idea that it was a Content issue
right and in a life experience issue
which is partially true it's not that
that's not true it's just not complete
and so then the solution is a Content
solution I'll you know initially
psychoanalysis all the way through kind
of modern forms of psychotherapy the
limitations of that led us to Psychiatry
2.0 right this idea that we
serendipitously found the first
antipsychotics and first
anti-depressants and we were able to
deinstitutionalize you know primarily
schizophrenia patients out of impatient
like Asylum stays with these drugs which
kind of flew in the face of this being a
Content issue what was the first antis
psychotic Thorazine I was going to say
Thorazine yeah yeah I don't want to take
you off track so keep track of where we
are we're at 2.0 how was it
serendipitously discovered it was like
an antibiotic or or something like that
and they were trying to develop that
drug out for something completely
unrelated and happen to give it to some
patients with schizophrenia and they had
a dramatic Improvement yeah I would love
to read a book that is just a collection
of case studies like this right yeah
it's like selenop right Viagra it's like
for Angina or whatever and then the male
patients are like why aren't their male
patients sending their meds back oh wait
a second that's right here we here we go
yeah that's all right so Thorazine and
the Serendip this discovery of oh wait a
[__]
second this seems to not necessarily
negate but certainly render incomplete
this pre-existing Paradigm yeah that's
right and then then where does it go
from there there was this accumulation
of assumptions around well if we're
moving all of these chemicals around in
the brain then it must be that there's a
deficiency or an imbalance or whatever
and that led us to recent history where
you know there's quite a bit of you know
prescribing of oral anti-depressants and
all that stuff and the third ERA this
kind of circuit era that I think we're
we're in now and I'd argue we kind of
were entering in 10 years ago but I
think we're pretty squarely at the the
beginning of now flies in the face of
that right if I can take a patient as
severe as dear dreman get her out of it
in a very quick time frame and and
looking normal and holding that for a
long time and there was no chemical
Exchange right there's nothing that went
into her
system then it gets you into this newer
way of thinking about it's a circuit
problem the useful thing about this
framing one it's seemingly consistently
true in the sense that we we're through
all the various modalities seeing these
differences but you know more
importantly it lets you integrate past
ideas into that concept right drugs act
on circuits therapy acts on circuits but
focal neurom modulation is a really
direct way of acting on those same
circuits and so from a patient
standpoint I think it's very empowering
because we're not saying there's
something inherently like missing or too
much for you you're constrained to
having to to take these these exogenous
chemicals to to kind of stay well but
rather like there's a circuit there's a
a miswiring sort of misfiring sort of
problem and if we can reroute that
information then you can feel well and I
think that there's a level of
empowerment that comes to that you know
one of the things that patients always
tell me after they get well with some of
our stimulation approaches is that they
kind of look at it and say well I may
get depressed again but I don't think
I'll ever get
suicidal that same level again because I
know that I've got a way of getting out
of it and it's my own valtion to choose
to do that and it's something I can
tolerate and I feel normal so I'd like
to highlight that last part because not
that I'm the world's foremost expert in
suicidal ideation but as someone who
came very close to offing himself in
college and really just by a series
of of Lucky events ended up not
fulfilling that it's the hopelessness I
mean for me and for a lot of people it's
the feeling that nothing can fix this I
am broken I am permanently broken there
is no option other than trying to
silence this voice in my head and the
only way I can think of doing that is by
ending my life
but once you see once you
experience even more so something that
alleviates that especially with any type
of durability doesn't need to be forever
but some type of durability and
especially if it's rapid acting right y
yep
yep then you feel like you you have a
plan B yeah right and that is incredibly
empowering let me ask
you a few questions the first
is this type of neuromodulation is that
synonymous with a term that I came
across I don't know who coined it it's
nice term electrocutica or are those
different it's part of that broader term
of electroceuticals yeah and so what we
had done I don't know if this is a good
time to kind of get into let's do it
what we had done with what we called San
or Stanford accelerated intelligent neur
modulation therapy is that we came up
with a way of
reorganizing conventional TMS which had
been around for some time reorganizing
it in time and in space right and so
with
conventional rtms that developed in the
mid 80s first used as a therapeutic
within clinical trials by my mentor Mark
George when he was in NIH in the mid 90s
approved by the FDA and the kind of mid
to late 2000s it utilized you know kind
of average skul positions to to find an
average spot to stimulate which you know
at the time given the technology that
was available that was the right call
right can I pause for one second just to
give some additional context what does
TMS stand for Trans cranial magnetic
stimulation and it was originally
developed for what as a motor probe by
Tony Barker in the UK and the idea is
this idea of Faraday's law so Faraday's
law is this idea that if you pulse a
magnet you can generate current and
electrically conducting substances so if
I take an electromagnet if I take a TMS
machine to the beach and I try to pulse
the sand nothing's going to happen
because sand is not as you know
electrically conducting at all it's an
insulator and so if you put a TMS coil
or any electromagnet next to a wire a
copper wire speaker wire or whatever you
can generate current in that wire if you
put the coil on the head it will bypass
the skin scalp skull and induce current
in the electrically conducting substance
in the brain the kind of brain tissue
right and so you're able to selectively
turn on cortical neurons Without Really
interacting with much of the rest of the
head people do feel something because of
the the nerves and the scalp but you
don't your brain can't feel anything so
so that's like scalp nerves and so as
they did in the ' 80s just kind of send
a single pulse it doesn't really change
the brain but you can probe the brain
right so I could take that coil from the
mid 80s and I could put it over my hand
representation to make my thumb move I
can put over my wrist representation of
my brain I can make my wrist move and
and it's organized in this stereotyped
way such that essentially the the head
face areas like closer to the ear and
you you can March up to the midline of
the skulls such that when you get to the
midline you're able to actually move the
foot and the leg if you have a if you
have a certain kind of coil you can do
that and so you can actually probe the
entire motor system and make all of it
move without having any volition to it
question what is the value of this probe
so the value of a probe itself is just
you know figuring out the mapping yeah
it's a mapping exercise initially right
like where is everything is it the same
and everybody is it consistent you know
and they wanted to kind of have a way of
doing that
non-invasively pinrose and others had
been doing this invasively as
neurosurgeons for 100 years I guess 50
years at that point and so they wanted
to be able
to to emulate what the surgeons could do
in epilepsy patients they're doing
epilepsy surgery non invasively and then
what folks realized over the next 10
years is we can send a signal into the
brain that's like moris code and
basically send the signal to change the
excitability of the brain and we can
measure it if we do it in Murder cortex
by how much the thumb moves with a set
amplitude out of the machine so if I get
X movement I can make from stimulating
here I can make the thumb move x amount
and then I send this moris code signal
into the brain to tell it to to tone
down or to kind of be less excitable and
then I send that same intensity back in
the thumb will move half as much MH and
so you've toned down cortical
excitability If instead I I get this
measurement of X and then instead of
putting in what we call inhibitory or
dep potentiating stimulating stimulation
we put in excitatory potentiating
stimulation into the brain and and we do
that and then we measure again it'll be
2x mhm so we knew by the mid 90s that we
could actually move around how excitable
the brain was in these normal healthy
control volunteer murder cortices and so
the aha moment for Mark and his team was
this idea that you know depression at
that time on pet scans on spec scans was
this kind of hypo activity hypo
metabolis ISM meaning lower lower yeah
lower activity lower metabolism of the
prefrontal cortex right where the
prefrontal cortex just isn't as active
isn't as
robust as it is in normal healthy
controls and so he had this idea well
could we use this excitatory stimulation
to drive up activity and so that was the
aha moment in the kind of first version
of this but they were you know super
careful there' been know some seizures
in the early days from trying to figure
out how all this works and so they
wanted to do a stimulation approach that
wasn't going to have much in the way of
risk and so they had this you know once
a day very extended protocol and because
of the you know the mid 90s it was very
hard to get cheap brain scans on
patients and so this idea that they were
going to have to use kind of average
coordinates to to Target it and so they'
get average skull measurements and then
they would do kind of a a low dose
sort of approach once a day and do that
out for for weeks and then it extended
out to months and so the original TMS
trials and the original approval was
this less
efficient version that basically
utilized kind of a low efficiency signal
into the brain and used kind of average
coordinates to place the coil so average
coordinates meaning just by clumsy
analogy like we can't take an x-ray of
you but we do have 100 other x-rays that
seem to indicate roughly this is where
you have your fracture so we're going to
aim at those coordinates that's right
yeah that's right and the once a day
protocol I've heard the number 36 from
somewhere but it's it's is it somewhere
in generally like the 30 to 40 session
range yeah that's exactly right so we're
looking at let's just call it for a
placeholder 30 to 40 sessions one per
day to perhaps not necessarily conjure
an image but remove an image from the
minds of some listeners they may be
thinking this this is a beautiful mind
this is somebody chomping down on a
wallet or a piece of wood getting
electroconvulsive therapy yep yep these
are not the same thing it's actually the
opposite the goal of electric convulsive
therapy ECT which has been around for
100 years is to produce a therapeutic
seizure and some people with
autobiographical memory troubles it's
pretty
underutilized as a treatment in
Psychiatry because of these issues
because of particularly One Flew Over
the Cuckoo's Nest and and that that
story and that that movie culturally has
actually had an impact on on ECT and
it's one of these things that's kind of
for a lot of patients elas Stitch Resort
because of the the concerns around this
you know the side effects TMS is
different right people you're not trying
to induce a seizure in fact you're
you're you're not trying to you know
have any sort of change in cognition I
always tell patients it's really boring
we have like Netflix running in the
background and people have their Netflix
movie that they keep watch watching
every day it's basically just once folks
get used to it it's just part of a a
routine where they're sitting there and
and watching their show or whatever it
is and the stimulator is turning the
brain on and unlike ECT there's no
anesthesia there's really no need for
anything you can do this in an
outpatient setting but the old forms of
of TMS are extremely slow you can't use
that in a psychiatric emergency and so
this is something that happens over a
couple of months and It's Tricky for
some people like if you're a working
person and you have to do TMS during you
know conventional TMS during kind of
business hours you basically have to
tell your boss or sneak out of the
office or whatever it is and go do an
hour and a half during the middle of the
day during like standard kind of Bankers
hours to be able to do this and it's
hard to do that over a couple of months
and it doesn't address these kind of
high Acuity emergencies and so we got
very interested in this idea of can we
like I said earlier reorganize the
stimulation in time and space space
being can we personalize it to each
person's brain I can talk about that in
Greater detail and then can we compress
these sixe courses in this case into a
single day so that's why Durer was able
to get well and in a day is because we
gave her a whole six week course in a
day you gave her how many sessions so
that's 10 triple do sessions and so it's
like 30 total equivalent sessions in a
day and so the FDA cleared 600 pulses of
itbs once a day 5 days a week for 6
weeks in 2018 and now was for a major
depressive disorder that was major
depressive disorder and so we we give a
triple dose every session so 1,00 pulses
and so after 10 sessions you've got the
equivalent of 30 sessions worth in that
first day and you do that for 5 days and
so people are getting the dose
equivalent of 7 and a half months worth
of TMs in 5 days surprising to us it was
this linear is that you know you just
pick up remitters as you progress
through the days what do you mean by
remitters people who completely lose all
of their depressive symptoms to a level
that is within the normal range um so
they're rating at the same level as
somebody who's not depressed you know we
can get people there on an average of
2.6 days and we're able to do that by
you know personalizing the Target and
then being able to deliver treatment
into that Target you know a lot of
treatment over a short period of time
and so what's useful about that is
somebody can be in a really pretty bad
state on Monday morning they can kind
take a week off of vacation or they may
end up being on the impatient unit or
whatever it is but they can you know go
out get this done and get back to work
in a time frame that's actually
reasonable and that was really our goal
how do we get people acutely out of
these high Acuity settings and into a
state of Wellness quick enough that they
that it doesn't make a major impact on
their lives may I add one thing to that
yeah which is I've had a number of
friends and I've certainly heard of many
cases where people with certain
professions airline pilots firefighters
police officers there are many more will
not report any type of mental health
issue because they'll be suspended in a
lot of cases or relieved of Duty right
they will they'll be forced to take time
off and in a case like this where you
have a compressed protocol there's the
possibility of say of taking PTO or
taking a week off and doing this
treatment whereas like you said doing it
during Bankers hours over months is
going to be highly visible right and
until the entire system changes which is
going to take time if it happens at all
this would be an incredibly attractive
alterable protocol if it were to work so
please continue that's the way that we
thought about it right is can we you
know take folks who who need to get get
well quickly I mean we had people in
conventional TMS courses where they
started they're in really bad shape they
lose their job halfway through maybe
they better at the end of it you know
but it took so long and so it's one of
these things if we can compress that up
and get them well in a short period of
time and get them out of it you know it
gets people back to their lives and it
has a low impact on I know I'm
interrupting a lot but the threading of
this I think is important so we can we
can sort of foreshadow something that is
going to be on the minds of a lot of
people which is what are the downsides
what are the risks so my question is
like was it easy to get the sort of
Ethics board approval to compress all of
this into a much shorter time frame was
able to make a compelling case to the
IRB and then eventually to the to the
FDA around safety and we give 90% of the
resting motor threshold that's depth
corrected for atrophy so if somebody if
it's an older patient they have more
prefrontal atrophy then you can increase
the intensity based off of that
difference and depth with the murder
cortex but essentially what their brain
is getting as 90% of the resting motor
threshold which is kind of a calibrated
number that's based off of this TMS
induced motor movements it gives us a
sense of how to dose the stimulation may
I translate that briefly I'm sorry sorry
to interrup so I'll show a bit of my
hand here which is I've I've undergone
two separate weeks with different
Hardware different protocols because i'
never want to talk about things like
this unless I've put
myself in the spaceship and been the
monkey shot into space which doesn't
mean at this point I I am a prozer one
100% for the treatment but I find it I
find it very compelling at least for
investigation so to just explain since I
recently went through this each morning
or certainly on the first morning but on
on multiple Mornings in my case they
will test your motor motor threshold
right and that could be a finger or a
hand it could be a foot and they'll
watch movement really closely and then
based on that determine the sort of dose
that will be delivered throughout the
day during these sessions and in my case
it was
you know once an hour for 10 hours a day
yep so please continue so it's just a a
way of getting the intensity and and
that you need and so we we know that 90%
meaning sub motor threshold there's
never been a a TMS related seizure for
that kind of sub motor threshold
intensity even you know giving multiple
sessions a day or whatever it is there's
never been an event like that it's
always been a higher kind of intensity
of the stimulation in the moment if that
makes sense so the amount of magnetic
field that's being put out in proximity
to the brain and so seems to be much
more related to that than it does the
amount of pulses that you receive in a
day and so I was able to lay that out to
the various regulatory bodies and show
the evidence that that threshold is
really the threshold where risk right
goes up it's sort of the strength of the
pulse not the frequency or the density
yeah exactly that it's it's more about
the the intensity and less about the the
density or the amount so laying that out
it was acceptable and various you know
parties deemed it to be non-significant
risk and they let us proceed now this is
FDA breakthrough status FDA cleared and
all the way through all of the
regulatory processes and so it's it's
kind of an on-label approach these days
but you know back then I had to make a
lot of those arguments and you know
knock on wood we we still haven't seen
any seizure how many people would you
say at this point have gone through
well-designed accelerated TMS I'd say
more than 4 or 500 between trials you
know we have trials where they're
ongoing and I don't know what the
clinical outcome of those trials are
because I'm blinded to them but I do
know that AES right we can know what and
we don't have any serious Adverse Events
in the sense we haven't had anybody have
a seizure that's good what you do see is
headache not everybody but but you know
fair you know percentage of people and
it's mainly related to the coil
activating scalp nerves and basically
kind of turning the facial musculature
on that actually goes away over time so
in the long term you actually see a
reduction in in migraine headaches and
you see a reduction in and pain all that
sort of thing and people actually have
an antios deceptive effect anti excuse
me anti- pain effect ah pain yeah what
was the word you used no acceptive oo
new one all right yeah yeah yeah yeah
and so you can actually have an anti-
pain effect and the reason why we think
that happens is cuz you actually anti-
pain meaning it could help with chronic
pain or something like this at least
acute experimental P pain there are some
chronic pain studies you can see that
you you release endogenous opioids from
from
stimulation because you can actually use
opioid blockers and block the anti-pain
effects of TNS so there's this whole
kind of pharmacos stimulation thing that
people are looking into buddy of mine
Joe Taylor who's at Harvard now did
these studies when he was in mdphd and
he was able to actually show that there
is this release and then you can kind of
block it with co-administration of of
opiate blocking drugs that's the idea is
that there is some acute potential
headache risk people can get a little
fatigued from this it's like fatigue
more like you ran a marathon instead of
like depression related fatigue you know
just from kind of being there all week
look end of one here but seems you know
I spent a lot of time talking to folks
as you know kind of my job my experience
was headache for sure I was I was
hesitant to take any type of Tylenol or
medication for that just because uh and
this is again as a naive lay person but
I was like well you know like if you do
take nids if you're doing say weight
training that can inhibit some of the
Adaptive response I'm not sure we fully
understand what the hell's going on here
like I'm I'm just going to deal with the
headache it was tolerable I mean you
could feel it the fatigue was the
fatigue that you might feel if you were
cramming for your final exams every day
it was not the fatigue of apathy and and
honia like the difficulty or
impossibility of finding joy in the
things you would normally find Joy with
like that type of fatigue is
characteristically Le very different
it's more like yeah you just crammed for
20 hours to try to nail your finals cuz
you didn't prepare and you're going to
do that every day that was the feeling
question for you then we're going to get
to the results I want you to discuss the
sort of results of of saint but I think
before we do that it's important to
maybe describe this patient population
is it is it fair to say that you're
seeing it would be an exaggeration May
to say the worst of the worst but you're
you're dealing with patients who have
had multiple failed interventions seems
like that's important to kind of keep in
mind if that is true yeah and so in our
randomized control trial people had an
average 9 years of the current episode
so they were depressed for 9 years on
average straight before they came into
our trial at five plus or minus two Med
failures and they had a a lifetime load
of depression of about 25 years so these
were folks who' had been depressed dress
with multiple episodes or very long
episodes they tried a lot of meds to get
out of those episodes not mild cases
right these are folks who've kind of
been through it for a long time and and
interestingly that's going back to the
the study that we talked about earlier
with the flipping of the signal that
flipping of the signal was correlated
with higher Modis scores and so the more
Modis is the assessment I'm sorry yeah
higher depression scores and so the
higher your depression rating the higher
likelihood you to have that that signal
from you know from the data that we that
we collected and so and that's what
we've seen right got it and the
switching just just to tie it back to
what we're talking about is that sort of
having the the wrong lead Domino or like
you have a car where you're trying to
start the diesel car without heating the
coil first yeah that's righte situation
yeah yeah yeah so it's that
directionality you know that's what
we've seen folks that are at that you
know that kind of more inst stage sort
of depression seem to do be more
responsive to this in those cases you're
really correcting this pretty dense
brain signaling problem if that PN work
replicates and what we've also seen is
folks that do really well with
dorsolateral at least or folks who are
have a pretty impaired attention and so
they actually score up on the
concentration item of the depression
scales and so that was um something we
observed earlier on that if you're if
you're saying you can't read a book
anymore you can't really you can't
really follow a you know recipe book to
cook your favorite meal or whatever
because you just can't attend to it then
your likelihood of getting better from
this is higher whereas folks that are
more on the kind of
obsessive depressive side of things that
don't complain as much about cognitive
problems and concentration problems but
more about their just ruminating and
kind of obsessing on things we found
that inhibiting the the right frontal
Pole or the frontal C Tech so
stimulating here and we have OCD trials
to do that is pretty effective at
shutting that down so it's more of a
shutting down than a turning up sort of
intervention some of it's actually the
illness intersects with the brain
anatomy intersects with like the
symptomatic presentation to try to you
know derive uh the best spot to
stimulate for for those folks and we
have some early studies now where we're
trying to use brain Imaging to actually
sort folks into into buckets neural
to figure out which Target makes sense
for their symptomatic presentation based
on their personalized fmri scans yeah I
think this would be a good point and
we'll mention this again at the end but
maybe you could mention any open trials
or if people would like to consider
enrolling or they know someone who might
want to become subject in studies or
anything you'd like to like to mention
so we have a number of trials that that
are ongoing at at the Stanford brain
stimulation lab so it's bs. stanford.edu
and you can go on the website and then
there's like a screening portal and
people can go on and fill out their
information and essentially we have
trials for for anodic depression we have
trials for standard severe treatment
resistant depression obsessive
compulsive disorder borderline
personality disorder patients who also
have depression bipolar depression some
addiction work that that my
collaborators are working on and so you
know folks have
that range of symptomatology happy to
have folks come through and screen it's
all free which is nice so it's all
basically funded through these trials
we're excited to to bring people in and
and see if it makes sense for them to
work with us on this and um it's a
couple of of week commitment what did
the results or what have the results
looked like with Saint or slight
permutations of that and how do they
compare to let's just say more
conventional treatments for these same
conditions so in our original pilot
study 90% of people experienced
remission at the post 90% 90% yep in the
randomized control trial it was 79% of
people transited through remission at
some point in the four-week followup
what's interesting is it's not all at
the same time point so if you look at
time Point by time point it's like in
the 50 to 60% range colleagues of mine
at Cornell Connor Liston and others have
have replicated this finding that 's a
subpopulation of patients that actually
has a slower time to remission and we've
seen this too they folks will lose their
suicidal ideation will actually Peak
their anti-depressant effect at one
month it's usually in older adults and
that's what we've seen is is basically
it's only in 50y olds and above we
haven't seen that that sort of delayed
remission that delayed remission yeah
but if you you know if you're putting
together 22 to 80y olds you're going to
have some of these folks but what's
interesting is a is TMS is also a probe
of the system if you kind of ignore the
kind of normal rules of how to Define
remission and you just ask the question
of who crosses through 79% of our active
group crossed through 133% of our
control group crossed through and that
tells you something I think about the
neuroanatomy you know that probably
something in the
70% of folks have this dorsolateral
singulate problem and then a version of
that thinking was seen in our PN
signaling paper too about 70% of those
folks had the flip and the signal and so
you know my suspicion is is that there's
a subpopulation of people who don't have
that who have some other you know
diagnosis probably looks a lot like
depression but is probably a different
neuroanatomy and we've seen this sort of
phenomenon happen in medicine before we
used to Cluster all the parkinsonism
together you know so there's lots of
reasons at parkinsonism some of those
reasons are idiopathic Parkinson disease
in the kind classic sense the way
idiopathic mean just that it's you know
kind of this spontaneous happening of of
Parkinson's disease that's the core
Parkinson's syndrome that we think about
Michael J fox and others and then you've
got other things that look like it
Progressive superclear Psy Louis body
dementia drug related
parkinsonism parallel to your like
diabetes presentation earlier yeah
exactly exactly we forever lumped all
these folks together and it really took
the UK brain bank and being able to link
in that case for Parkinson's link
Parkinson's pathology to symptomatic
presentation is the UK brain bank and
how I've never heard of this I mean
there's lots of brain Banks or brain
donation uh entities physical brains or
are we talking about scans physical
brains after death postmortem donations
so there's a lot of ways you can you can
donate if you have a neuros psych
disease you can donate your brain to
science and and so a lot of Parkinson's
patients donated their brains to to this
brain Bank to try to understand what it
is and what they found was and with with
like a deep clinical phenotyping before
death right and so then folks you had
this kind of deep phenotyping and then
after death they were able to D sorry
what do you mean by Deep phenotyping
like a deep kind of understanding of the
symptomatology right so basically you
know does this person's trimmer did
their do their trimmer happen on one
side or both sides at the same time how
do things present how do things present
in an observable way that's right
exactly in the same way just folks you
have like genotype phenotype right like
so this would be similar idea okay yeah
yeah so they so basically what they
found was clinically people that have
the kind of standard Parkinson's disease
typically tend to have a presentation of
unilateral onset illness right where one
side of the body or the other is much
worse from a parkinsonian standpoint
than the other and it's actually very
common for people with Parkinson's to
present where you know if it's a leg
onet Parkinson's or foot's dragging or
trimmer just in one hand right and
that's actually what you would expect
from normal Parkinson's if it's like
really symmetric it's it's less likely
to be that it's more likely to be
something else and they figured that out
from essentially the brain biology and
forming that being able to link up
substan [__] problems they found on
autopsy with symptoms I I think we're in
an a at the beginning of an era in
Psychiatry to be able to do the same
sort of thing to take what's lumped
together as depression or anxiety or
whatnot and to be able to parse it into
a lot of different what we call biotypes
or Indo you know people think about as
endophenotypes or whatever these kind of
specific kind of flavors of that
symptomatology some linked with a you
know very specific brain physiology or
brain functional neuroanatomy such that
you can say that this depression type
one needs this treatment depression type
two needs this treatment and so on and
so forth and so that's that's really
from my vantage point the the future
right is being able to a single patient
level be able to figure out something
about their brain and then help that use
that to help to prescribe what the next
step is for them you know if we can do
that we can we can also cut time right
because we can go straight to the effect
treatment for people and cut all the
time around diagnosis and it's not just
time it's risk right in in a lot of
these cases absolutely it's risk from
you know potentially the wrong treatment
it's also risk from waiting cost
potentially also right it's also cost
yeah so so as you as you know right like
there's a period of time where the
diagnosis is uncertain and then there's
a period of time where the treatment is
uncertain right so for bipolar
depression the average length of time it
takes to diagnose know somebody with
bipolar disorder from a depressive
episode onset so they come in with
depression and depression's their
primary you know presentation s years
till you get them right it's wild right
and then that's just to get to that
point now you're on the right realm of
medications or whatever now you're
talking about in year seven you're
having to spend whatever it is like
three five seven more years trying to
find a solution so you could go from
being you know 25 years old having this
be your first depressive episode and
you're still trying to figure out what
you're going to do about it at 40 you
see these patients I'm just imagining
you're like reaching into a dark closet
and there's a what you think is a screw
head and you're just trying different
tools but you're not allowed to touch
the screw head that's it versus like
let's flip on the light take a
photograph yeah and then go find the
appropriate tool for the job just a
couple of followup s the numbers that
you're mentioning right the remission
rates the people who who pass through so
to speak yeah how does that compare to
like Frontline conventional treatments
right now so there's a study called
stard D it's a little it's been an
interesting year for stard D in the
sense that some people have reanalyze
that data and there's open questions
about what the percentages are as far as
what percentage of people make it to you
know a remitted state after going
through this algorithm but essentially
stard D started with a pretty low
side effect burden oral antidepressant
sat talopram and then kind of transited
through you know higher risk sort like
snris and Psychotherapy and lots of
other what's the trade name for ES
alpram what do you know people would
know Lexapro Lexapro got yeah those
drugs you know and then you go to like
asiner like AER in lexine and then into
like the tricyclics and the monom
oxidase Inhibitors and so people would
go through this algorithm and they pop
out on the other end after five or six
or seven different treatments and and
then then they would they'd ask the
question of after people go through all
of this what's their remission rate so
that number's kind of been called into
question but essentially when you get
into like Med 4 which is roughly where
Insurance used to start to pay for TM
conventional TMS conventional TMS would
beat that pretty pretty well like almost
double compared to you know you're
talking about lithium or thyroid hormone
things like that when you start getting
into that step and conventional TMS
would beat that when you get to those
kind of next even more severe steps you
start to lose efficacy with conventional
TMS so you go from like a remission rate
of around 30% with conventional TMS down
to about 16% when you get into the
higher treatment resistance levels
that's the levels that we ran our trials
on which really that you know where
people normally get about 16% remission
with conventional TMS that that's where
we were seeing those numbers could you
just repeat those numbers where you
seeing what numbers in our open label
trial 90% and our randomized control
trial depending upon how you look at it
it's in like the 50 60% at at each time
point or 79% if you're asking did people
Transit through remission at any point
versus 16% not and this wasn't like a
head-to-head it's not a head to think
but but just just so people have some
means of comparison and in terms of
pharmaceutical interventions at that
point very low I mean you're talking
about sub 10% efficacy you know this is
around where where electri convulsive
therapy is thought about right this kind
of therapeutic seizure thing we were
talking about earlier that's got about a
48% remission rate but it's not fast
either and you definitely can't work the
day you get it and there's this
autobiographical memory things you're
talking about a like conventional TMS
like a 1 to two month commitment and
then quite a bit of risk for side
effects there you know you've got
ketamine which produces about a 30% spot
remission rate with a single infusion
and that goes up as you administer more
ketamine treatments with the IV ketamine
forms but you know as you go from a
single infusion to what they did in this
New England Journal paper that was
published a couple months ago like you
know six treatments over a couple of
weeks it starts to accumulate more time
and so we're able to you know from from
my standpoint we're able to get the most
bang for your buck the quickest and with
the least kind of interruption in I
think people's ability to do stuff
during that time but there you know
there are other things ketamine Cy and
other other psychedelic drugs that I
think you've you've thought about and
talked about on this show before that
are are also coming over the next couple
years few follow-up comments and
questions so you mentioned a number of
things uh borderline personality
disorder bipolar as as two examples part
of the reason that I'm so interested in
neurom modulation right now accelerated
TMs in particular although I'm also
interested and other things uh that I
know less about like focused ultrasound
and so on which we might get into if we
have time is that many of the conditions
that would be screened out that would be
exclusionary criteria in say a
psychedelic assisted Psychotherapy trial
yeah are eligible for this type of
treatment right which is which is
incredibly interesting there are people
who might have something that is more
common extreme hypertension some type of
like ocular issue where phys logically
psilocybin shouldn't technically pose a
risk but if they have a lot of panic
rapid heart rate Etc there might be
complications right elderly patients Etc
so part of the reason this entire realm
of treatment possibilities with neurom
modulation is interesting is because
these tools could be available to people
who will not who would not be good
candidates for some of these other
things that you're mentioning what I'd
love to ask you about because this has
been one of the questions that just
stuck in my head the topic of delayed
remission so having these patients I
can't remember the the number I was
looking at some of the charts maybe it
was three or four people out of N of6 I
can't recall that's right okay there we
go who had this remission at like week
four or something like that how do you
explain this and why is it older
patients or does it seem to be older
patients and and how do you relate it to
a few things right so in the case of say
ssris some folks also have this like a
lot of people like delayed onset of
benefits right and then you have
ketamine this is going to be a bit of a
sloppy question but I'm sure you can
clean it up for me uh you then you have
ketamine which is very rapid acting and
I have heard I I do not have the
credibility or the the means of parsing
all of this like okay well ketamine and
acts directly on nmda receptors seems
like maybe ssris do that but in a very
indirect way and that explains the
delayed benefits in some patients don't
know if that's true or not don't know if
I'm even wording that correctly how do
you kind of tie this to or not the
delayed remission cuz I'm just like how
does that even work right I'm like okay
if you put a drug in someone's head and
it triggers a Cascade or maybe it
triggers some type
of exceptional neurot plasticity that
then shows the fruits of that at Weeks
whatever 2 3 4 okay I haven't been able
to figure out like a plausible mechanism
for the accelerated TMS and that delayed
remission how do you think about that
like even if it's speculation yeah it
would be speculation but I think you
know so we've only seen in older adults
you know we know the brain plasticity in
older adults goes down as a generality
and there are lots of metrics about why
folks think that as you talked about
earlier really it's it's cramming for a
test you're actually sending a memory
signal into the brain so the the
stimulation pattern you're sending into
the brain is kind of moris code is
really a turn on stay on remember to
stay on memory signal that's going into
the brain and you're just basically
taking the hippocampus the a part of the
brain that's involved at memory and and
like that signaling that comes out of
there and you're playing that back
through the prefrontal cortex in a way
to try to tell the pref frontal cortex
to turn on stay on and remember to stay
on and I think I think part of what's
going on is because that you know older
brain is a little less likely to have
kind of flexibility plasticity it takes
some time for the signal to kind of
fully lay its tracks into the brain we
don't have any sort of biology to to
kind of back that up yet but what we're
doing right now and we we haven't
analyzed this data yet is we're actually
scanning people every single day and
we're scanning people multiple times out
to the month and I funed by scanning you
mean fmri fmri scanning yeah yeah so
we're actually getting like 10 scans
spread out over it's a lot of coughing
time it's a lot yeah yeah yeah we you
know people have been been very cool
about this uh and so we've been able to
potentially spell some of this out right
right like why why are these delayed
remitters happening but I my suspicion
is is that it's probably plasticity
related issue interestingly you know
ketamine and and TMS may have more in
common with each other than than one
would initially think right like a lot
of the the TMS effects are probably in
part glutamate related is ketamine and
then as we talked about earlier there's
an endogenous opioid release from TMS um
we've done some work with opioid related
mechanisms in ketamine and there's
probably a
Confluence of not one neurotransmitter
system but like a an orchestra of
neurotransmitter systems that are being
affected across these interventions and
you know it's my suspicion that that's
probably what needs to happen in order
for these treatments to be effective and
our old views on you know this kind of
chemical imbalance sort of 1990s view of
like one neur transmitter one
neurotransmitter receptor you know sort
of problem in the brain is way too
simplistic and that it's probably a lot
more complic as as one would imagine a
lot more complicated than that outside
of accelerated
TMS if you're looking out say over the
next 5 years for Rapid acting
potentially durable anti-depressant
effects what other tools or molecules or
treatments are most interesting to you
yeah so we have a paper coming out soon
in nature medicine on looking at at Iain
as a potential treatment for in this
case for military traumatic brain injury
but a lot of these folks had depression
generalized anxiety disorder and and
PTSD and so it was a it was an
interesting that was another interesting
story so I was approached back in 2018
by a professor a senior professor at
Stamford who was tapped by some folks to
kind of find somebody who'd be willing
to partner with a a nonprofit called
vets of the time who were sending and I
think you've you've interacted with with
Amber Marcus Capone a little bit I
interviewed Rick Perry and Rick doblin
two years ago at their their uh Veterans
Day fundraiser yeah I was there I
remember that was an interesting one
yeah you know we partnered up with them
I had to again go to the Stanford IRB
and ask them for another edgy and you
know you have to give the Stanford IRB
credit could you just spell out IRB oh
sorry institutional review board it's
the entity that reviews all all research
protocols at at at institutions and so
this is the kind of governing body
that's in place that's been around for
about 100 years that essentially is a a
non-conflicted uninvolved group of
senior professors that look at your
proposed research and then determine if
it's ethical and safe and answering the
questions that you think you're going to
answer and so just like going to them to
to talk through doing accelerated you
know TMS and saying we were able
to talk to them about doing a study
where people would come to Stanford
knowing in the IRB knowingly agrees to
them then going down to Mexico to take a
an illegal in the US uh root bark
extract that's um been utilized for
Millennia in the country of gaban and
related areas in in Central West Africa
and as you can imagine this was not a
quick turnaround uh nor should it have
been for the IRB in the sense that I had
to convince them this was science worth
doing at that time though you're is it
fair to say you're the TMS guy or was it
like in the air that you also had an
interest in
exploring something like an iboga or an
ibigan people knew that I was very
open-minded to things and I'm a
pragmatist right I mean for me like the
patient the most important thing the you
know I have this view of Psychiatry that
it's going to look like card impatient
Cardiology in 20 years where we're going
to use drugs we're going to use devices
we're going to be able to figure out
what the best things is for that patient
to to your point you know some of these
things are good
for different problems and so you know I
think that was known that I was open to
that we we' just been running this
ketamine mechanism trial and so I was I
was tapped to look at this and a couple
other people too and uh I found out
later they had gone to like a lot of
people and apparently I was like the
only person that was willing to do this
trial like I felt kind of special back
then and then like later realized that
like oh wait a second I was on the The
Bachelorette and I didn't even realize
yeah I was on The Bachelorette and I
didn't realize and The Bachelorette was
a tricky one we ended up reluctantly
agreeing to this and and admittedly like
I almost pulled out a couple of times
because ibigan has this street knowled
and academic knowledge that it has a
death risk right it has a one roughly
one in 300 risk of death from torsades
day point this arhythmia fatal arhythmia
that can happen with certain cardiac
acting drugs and it works through this
what they call hrg pottassium Channel
other things do this or like FDA cleared
like cancer drugs and arhythmia drugs
that'll do it too so it's not in context
it's like something that happens with
lots of different uh drugs that we use
but I think there was a somewhat of a
stigma and a bias around particularly an
addiction drug folks had been trying to
get this through you know the FDA and
through VAR NIH and whatnot in the 9s
Howard lot off and others and it was a
very complicated drug and I'd known
about it since residency i' read about
it I thought that like wow this is like
the most promising anti-addiction drug
on the planet right but you know I
thought it was completely unstudied and
I kind of like doing my other stuff and
then at that point how did you come
across iig again like where did you find
it 2012 2010 I think would this been
like early Deborah Mash stuff or no no I
come across this book breaking up in the
head by Daniel pinch yeah I think he
wrote for the New Yorker or something
and uh and I was stuck I was like going
kite surfing in South America and I was
stuck in the San Salvador airport and
there was like five English speaking
books or something and I picked this
book up uh in the airport like stuck
that was in the San Salvador airport wow
got a hold of this book read it waiting
on my flight which was like 8 hours
delayed to get to Peru and so yeah he he
just like lays the whole thing out it
was very interesting like he talks about
you know his own personal experience of
it and I read a lot about it there was
some work that that folks like Ken Alper
and others had published on the kind of
case report level outcomes but then also
the cardiac problems so then I found you
know I figured it was kind of unstudied
in 2018 I was approached was asked to do
this trial and so we went to the IRB
spent a year back and forth and like
right when they were about they approved
it co hit so we were actually supposed
to start right when Co happened and it
paused the whole thing and then it took
a while while to get it back online but
uh it was actually the quickest
recruiting study I've ever run we got 30
people done in like 8 months now is that
because of the sort of category of like
potential death of Despair I mean is is
it because of the patient population
were you dealing with addicts so the
patient population was and that was the
unique part about this it was Veterans
with traumatic brain injury some of
which were alcohol use disorder so you
know we we used to call alcoholism but
more than a third like I think 13 or 14
people out of the 30 but everybody had
TBI a lot of them most of them had
depression most of them had PTSD and so
you know we're running this trial I was
put like my best neuropsychology postto
on it and a couple other superstars and
it was running in the background and I I
was like you know we'll get this into
pretty good journal or whatever thinking
we'd see some people get better some not
whatever I was asked to give a a talk
about it at one at a very prestigious
University and asked the postto we just
wrapped up the immediate post and asked
the postto to put the data together and
we' have data to present for them and
they showed me like the clinical
outcomes and I was like completely blown
away it was like way better than I think
we anticipated very consistent
improvements and like basically
everybody some people would lose it you
know before the month but most people
held it and they're holding it out to a
year now and I was flored I actually
told them to delete all the code and
start start the analysis over because
they had to have done something wrong in
the math which is always fun the postto
always they kind of say yes and look at
you you just ruin my weekend um and so
so we uh we we did it again and it was
the same exact finding so they I was
wrong they were right they had done it
right the first time you know really
really striking and by the time this
will come out you know nature medicine
will have published this somewhat
prestigious yeah somewhat you know top
five biomedical journals in the world
and they it's like being nominated for
best picture at the Academy Awards I
mean scientific speaking it's it's a
it's a nice it's up there it's up there
it's a nice deal and it's it was very
surprising that that for me that that
they were going to be open to to
publishing an open label paper which you
know historically you're going to
publish in that kind of a journal like a
randomized trial so just for clarity
sake for folks listening so open label
means no placeable control right and
also to just rewind for a second I want
to mention to people that for
Accelerated TMS how do you know it's not
placebo effect you mentioned the control
group that's a sham treatment right like
you're basically people feel like
they're getting a treatment but they're
not actually getting the proper
treatment yeah in that case you want to
ask a blind guess and that's actually
been a big I was going to get into here
a big problem with the with a lot of the
Psychedelic trials and why there's a lot
of criticism for a lot of the
Psychedelic trials is that they kind of
know that the blind guest is going to be
uh uh highly skewed so there's one trial
where they did siloc cyb and for alcohol
use disorder I it was like 99% correct
blind guess rating um so the P value is
highly sign ific in our Saint studies to
to my like great surprise our blind
guess was chance what do you mean by
blind guess you know Mr Smith you these
are the experimenters trying to guess
who is in which this is the patients
trying to guess what they got I see yeah
so Mr Smith you you know you just
wrapped up your treatment which
treatment did you get you know active or
sham what's your confidence got it in
what you got and and so what we found
which is really interesting for Saint
was that I talked to the I didn't know
what they what people got but I talked
to some of these people and I heard some
of this so it was really interesting
patients who' gotten totally better and
they'd say things like yeah you know I
just got lucky with Placebo this time
and they ended up getting getting active
and then folks that didn't get any
better that the god sham would say
things like you know I'm not even good
enough to respond to like the active
treatment so they so so it was confusing
enough for them where they were making
the wrong guess 50% of the time which is
what you what you're looking for is
about 50% error rate and it's a coin
toss sidebar on that I know this is very
like kind of staccato the way that I'm
trying to hold this conversation but
having gone through two weeks different
Hardware different practitioners Etc uh
and having had a lot of conversations
with technicians and so on it also seems
like for some people it takes a while
for their narrative to catch up with
like the hardware upgrade right in the
sense that they they say well maybe I
got lucky or maybe I don't really feel
that much and yet their assessments are
improving and or their significant
others see dramatic changes right that's
not specifically a a TMS effect or san
effect accelerated TMS effect that's
true I think for a lot of treatments
I've had calls in since our data has
been out on iaame where I've had people
call me and say hey Mr or Mrs so and so
like we they like like look amazing and
they don't think they're better so I
think you can see it across the board
psychedelics there's a certain problem
called Alexia and about 25% of people
treatment resistant to depression Lex
ayia yeah and so a meaning without Lex
meaning like the ability to describe
thyia mood and so they have a an
inability to to accurately rate their
mood and the way you know that is Alexia
I'm going to use that at a fancy
cocktail party soon Tim how you doing
sorry got
Alexia oh sorry you may better know that
as difficulty to describe mode yeah
that's right
that's sorry I I'll I'll try to back off
on the medic
medical J I like it I'm learning all
sorts of words it's an interesting
phenomenon and you see this in
psychiatric conditions people just have
like a like if you ask them very
specific questions like well when's the
last time you've been sad or thought
about anything negative oh it's like
been a week or two are you depressed yes
why do you know that I don't know it's
also like a self-reporting problem too I
think in some cases right it's like if
you ask someone like how many calories
you eat yesterday like most people would
be off by like 30 to like 60% or
something right yeah that's right and
and I I think the remedy for that is
that you have a clinician Raider and the
clinician Raider asks these really
really pointed very detailed questions
and then the patient able to answer and
then it's like a it's like a formula to
calculate what that mood rating is in
that case and sometimes it's just off
from what their perception is but when
you they're kind of meta perception of
the whole thing but when you get down to
the the brass Texs they're answering
right and so we we've seen that and
that's that's been that's been true
across these problems and there's ways
of constructing trials to deal with that
but yeah we've seen that with with
psychedelics as well we went after uh
military TBI yeah we were just really
surprised and one of the biggest and
these were all Special Operations mhm
yeah they were basically all former Army
Rangers former Navy Seals and there's
been a big cohort of these folks that
have gone down I mean some people in
Congress have gone down and done this
and spoken about it publicly I mean it's
National Defense authorization act the
NDA I think is just um you know went
through the Senate and the house both
approved it and think yesterday and it's
going to Biden you know to earmark money
for for Iain for uh trials you know
which is pretty cool so the military
community and some of the government is
pretty aware that that this is a
possibility there's been a lot of
advocacy that Amber and Marcus have been
involved in my hope is that you know
coming out of a journal like nature
medicine that really kind of validates
what we were seeing and put some context
to what we observed and what we found in
our study will help to to Spur more
funding and more focus and I think the
the kind of Veteran psychedelic angle is
is an important one you know for like a
lot of ethical moral reasons and you
know and a lot of also have like a
political immunity bracelet right so
it's a very important subpopulation and
it's very fortunate that it aligns with
sort of driving forward the
research around these therapeutic tools
it was super cool to work with those
guys I mean I I think and this was a
monotherapy in the sense that it was
just IB and I know that at least in many
places in Mexico they sometimes combine
it well they don't combine it but they
sequence it with 5m DMT at the tail end
was this iig gain alone yeah so it was
ibigan alone and then we had folks come
back like later to do the 5mo outside of
this kind of month followup period the
data that were publish in nature
medicine is just the Iain effect it was
tricky to kind of divorce those two
together cuz that's what's been going on
as you know in Mexico quite a bit so all
the acute out to the one month effects
are all direct Iain effects and it's
it's you know super cool and the thing
that that I found really interesting
about this drug is that it
produces what I think is probably the
most stereotyped trip if you want to
call it or the psychological phenomenon
that that happens along onside the drug
effects and so people will describe this
earlier life autobiographical replaying
of emotionally Salient memories that are
kind of epoched in time and so and
they'll some people got we got Life
review right Life review or slideshow
yeah exactly and so you know it's
interesting everybody's kind of got a
different different version of what the
slideshow ends up playing out to be like
for them and so some people would say I
found myself in this room and it was
like my TV from childhood and all of a
sudden it was playing all these things
or I found myself in a Hall of Mirrors
and I was playing all these things so
like the context can be very different
you know but the act the mind seems to
shape that but the actual replay seems
to be pretty stereotyped stereotype
meaning like this it's a pattern that
repeats or it's it just like a common
characteristic it's a common
characteristic and it's you know closed
eye only it's not open eyes it's not for
a lot of people the the Ian experience
is kind of really around this this part
this kind of Replay part that happens
and from what I have heard there's
there's kind of a a
cathartic re-evaluation of these
memories and in and interestingly an
ability to not only have insights into
your own reasons which may have been
good or bad for feeling or behaving or
doing whatever it was but also reasons
for they have some insight in the
reasons for the other which to me is
like the hardest thing to explain
it's it's almost like you knew it whole
you say it one more time say the last
part again so when they when people have
this slideshow or Life review they seem
to have it as a as a third- party person
in the experience you know like what is
this Christmas Carol Scrooge or whatever
when they go back in they go back in
life and you see like you become the
Observer of your own past experience
right it's kind of like that like
Scrooge goes back and sees himself as a
kid sees himself as like when he broke
up with his significant you know all
that stuff it's almost like that like
you're having a similar sort of thing
I've used the analogy of Tom Cruz in The
Minority Report right where you're able
to go back and see these events and and
what's so fascinating and why I've why
I've said and I I continue to say I
think this is the most sophisticated
drug on the planet is that I think that
there's nothing else that can seem to do
this right where you have these
experiences where you you're able to
hold this neutral place and you're able
to have this sense of where you were and
why you did what you did and you have
the sense of the other and you're able
to I don't know intu it you know empath
I I don't know what that is you you
somehow you know stored it at the time
and you weren't able to fully access it
and you're able to access it whatever
that is being able to forgive or to
forget or to understand this person's
position as well as your own and then
seemingly like unlock the lock on both
sides and then kind of tosolve the the
problem people say they'll they kind of
would work through all of this and you
know there's one one veteran you know
would say I went through all this
military stuff and at the back of of the
room it was my Early Childhood trauma
you know and so this idea that that at
the core of it for a lot of this ends up
being a childhood trauma thing that's
kind of buried below all of it and
really being able to actually both
access that in a way that you can
understand understand that many cases
the traumatizer was themselves
traumatized and that it's a pattern of
trauma and the ability to kind of
resolve it by understanding at this kind
of you know more meta empathic Viewpoint
and so that's why I think the tool is
really going to be important you know is
this ability to have what seems to be a
pretty profound or atrophic effect you
we were able to see disability
improvements from traumatic brain injury
but also this pretty pronounced kind of
cathartic re-evaluation reconsolidation
of of past life you know problematic
memories all right as I want to do let
me hop in with just a a few comments
that we can we can bounce around if we
want and then a whole bunch of questions
so the first comment is with the Special
Operations vets who are friends of mine
what I've observed maybe similar to what
you're describing that is part of what
has contributed to them being extremely
high performers in these high stress
environments is their ability to tightly
compartmentalize which they developed
when they were traumatized as kids Y
super high overlap like incredibly High
overlap of course there are many other
factors that contribute to them being
like the one person out of 10,000 who
doesn't get washed out of training right
being that
unbreakable in a sense but I with those
friends and look it's a tiny sample size
but of those friends like I wouldn't say
any of them would claim to have PTSD or
moral injury like a feeling of having
done the wrong thing but the TBI and
this is where I want to lead into a
question which is not to negate the fact
that a lot of people could have of
course meet the diagnoses for complex
PTSD and so on with the TBI what makes
Iain different from some of these other
psychedelics and um I want to say one
maybe place to explore would be gal
cells am I making this up G derive
neurotrophic Factor yeah g derive
neurotrophic Factor there we go what
makes a difference in terms of
mechanisms of action therapeutic effect
compared to some molecules people might
be more familiar with psilocybon or or
otherwise the classic psychedelic like
ayban as you know primarily affect the
the 5 ht2a receptors right so they're 5H
t2a Agonist they produce these kind of
classic psychedelic experiences from
largely from that that receptor you can
selectively knock out 5 hd2a receptors
you can knock out the Psychedelic effect
so we we've largely thought about kind
of this class of psychedelics in that
way you know ibigan is a no neurogen so
it produces a dreamlike state some
people call it an atypical psychedelic
you know we've elected to kind of use
this a neurogen term because I think it
more accurately reflects what's going on
in the trip and in the you know in the
way of kind of perceiving what it is it
does have some 5H t2a action but that's
probably the minority of the effect it
affects a broad range
of other receptor systems so like salvia
for instance is a Kappa Agonist right
there's Kappa mu effects there's nmda
effects with ibigan there's C effects so
serotonin effects and then there's this
upregulation of of bdnf brain derive
neurotrophic factor and gdnf CLE derive
neurotrophic factor and so and both of
those are you know profound neurotrophic
factors for plasticity in the brain the
the problem is is this has been you know
psychedelics were thought of as
relatively obscure 15 20 years ago to
study obviously that's changed now but
Iain is extremely obscure right so there
were a handful of studies that were
performed in good in published in good
journals over time but it's very limited
in the data that we have so far so it's
it's hard to like give you some sort of
definitive answer what I can tell you is
that it was a paper published you know I
think 15 or 20 years ago where they they
took mice and they got them to self-
administer alcohol so that's kind of
like a way of like an addiction model or
whatever alcohol self admin rtion or
sucrose self administra sugar self
Administration it's like a way of kind
of getting you can you can put cocaine
in the water and get addiction yeah
exactly and so if you give a mouse IBN
you can get them to stop
self-administering alcohol it's
interesting we saw that in humans I
stopped drinking as well in our our
study in this case you could actually
drill a small hole in the mouse's brain
you can inject gdnf directly into the
ventral tal area the area that produces
dopamine for the for kind of more of the
pleasure seeking part of the brain and
it it emulated the same effect as the
Iain right so this gdnf effect in the
dopamine system at least and gdnf is
thought to regulate dopamine neurons I
think that that's probably at least a
pretty strong part of it and what makes
it so unique I always tell people like
when I'm talking about this ibigan stuff
if we gave one of the the big Pharma
companies hundred billion dollar and
said you know don't don't just like
resynthesize ibigan but make a drug that
works like ibigan I think even some of
the classic psychedelic specifically I
began I think they'd have a hard time
doing it because we don't have the
Neuroscience to understand what's going
on there and I think it's because it's
not a one receptor yeah it's not it's
not super clean in that way it's like
promiscuous it's like people use that
term dirty drug I I think it's it has
the wrong connotation but yeah yeah like
LSD is pretty kind of promiscuous on I
like to think about it like a symphony
there we go right like you're you're
interacting with these neurotransmitter
systems in proportions in such a way
that it produces this effect you know my
suspicion is it's probably more
sophisticated than we want to attribute
to I mean maybe not you but like the
scientific Community wants to attribute
to Nature being able to pull off you
know but it's this idea that maybe
somehow we have this drug that just
happens to work the way it works because
it's able to interact with these systems
and in pretty important ratios or pretty
important kind of you know simultaneous
effects and that's really what's driving
it and and that's the part I'm saying
it's going to be hard to reproduce I
mean obviously Sasha shog and others
were able to take you know to emulate
similar sort of 5 ht2a effects but I
don't even think he was able to produce
an ibigan like multi-receptor sort of
symphony like this there hasn't really
been another drug like it in this way
and so you know trying to trying to
think about what that is and how to
really had to study it it's going to
take a a new you know new wave of
Neuroscience tools to be able ble to
capture all the effects in real time
Symphony of followup questions
okay and so I'll give you you can choose
this is this is dealer's Choice you're
the dealer okay so we we could go with
and we will get to all these but
improving the safety profile of I which
I should also say like I've had people
reach out to me which is always can be
very uncomfortable for me but like
friend like a friend of a very close
friend and in this particular case
someone's sister was a heroin addict who
is now homeless a acting as a prostitute
like living under an
overpass and the reason I bring up all
that the the that level of detail is
that for a lot of interventions in this
case I began at that point the cardiac
risk or some of the risk risks were
known and there's a question of is this
risky and the followup is compared to
what and in this particular conversation
it was well she could die tomorrow from
an OD or this and the other thing so so
I'm just kind of setting the table with
that but improving the safety profile
right is is one question another because
you mentioned the cessation of or like
the minimizing of the AUD right so like
people stopping drinking y uh we were
also talking before recording people
stopping drinking caffeine I guess or
coffee we okay unexpected presumably and
so my my question there which I sort of
seated because I mentioned I would want
to talk about this it's like any overlap
in terms of mechanism or how does this
compare to something like semaglutide
right like an OIC or some of the the the
newer gen I think it's Monaro maybe I'm
getting that wrong the last one and I've
been wanting to ask somebody about this
so we you mentioned 5 ht2 a mhm it seems
like some psychedelics exert effects
also on 5 ht2 b receptors and if I'm not
mistaken there's there's some data to
suggest that that can continued
stimulation like agonism of that B can
lead to some type of cardiac
complication as well like some type of
like ventricular
vales valves exactly so it so the the
question there is do you think that
micro doing for instance just become all
the rage could that potentially have
long-term negative cardiac effects the
FDA guidance document for psychedelics
that they released actually like on the
last day of the Psychedelic science
meeting which was really interesting is
uh specifically has a section about this
issue of cardiac valvular problems from
these more classic psychedelics the
problem with ibigan is is different
right the problem with ibigan is that it
it interacts with her potassium Channel
there are a number of of groups Folks at
Columbia Folks at U UC Davis who have
looked at this and their solution is to
modify the molecule and to affect it in
such a way that that it no longer
interacts with her that you do mean like
nor Iain or something like that or is it
more of a nor Iain the primary
metabolite of iban that goes after 2d6
is a normal part of the ibigan process
has a similar cardiac risk oh does
profile so it's it's drugs that are I
think they called them like tabern logs
or something but iboga logs or something
I think is what what was coined at at at
Davis but essentially these are drugs
where they like try to engineer off that
interaction which may or may not have an
effect I want to answer the question I'm
trying to ask and the question I'm
trying to ask is does I Iain help with
certain you know human illness by
modifying the molecule it's not ibigan
anymore it's something else and then
you're asking the question is does
something else help maybe it's close
enough to ibigan to do something similar
and I've taken like a different stance
on this where I've basically taken the
frame of how do you preserve the
molecule and really lean in on the
cardiac risk right and so one of the
ways and we how do you put an airbag in
the car instead of redesigning the whole
yeah instead of making it a an Airborne
uh shuttle or I don't know whatever
putting an airbag in with a you know
with a high likelihood of of saving the
person and and so we talk about this in
the article but essentially um you know
all the patients that were
treated
received
torsades like IV magnesium you know at
the start right what type of magnesium
so it's like magnesium sulfate so it's
basically just like IV bag magnesium and
so what's really interesting about this
arhythmia torsades that everybody's
worried about is that the treatment for
it per the American Heart Association
guidelines is to give IV magnesium which
is incredibly safe right and I've given
many times for various things in the ER
and you can just give it to people and
you know you'll eventually urinate it
out or whatever and so you know you can
give it get people through this risk
period and then they'll you know they
may be you know slightly hypermnesic or
a little high on their magn them in
their blood and they'll go out and
everything's all good and you know there
have been about a thousand operators
that have gone down to Mexico so far and
to my knowledge and we looked into this
pretty significantly there hasn't been a
single case of torsades conversely like
the New Zealand study that was published
a couple years ago they had a death out
of 10 people right and so you know we
we're not doing head-to-head I can't
tell you for sure what what the deal is
there but my suspicion is is that if you
give what is the treatment for the
problem you're worried about before you
give the the thing that can cause that
problem then it's much more likely that
you knock out the risk or significantly
reduce the risk it's also about doing it
in a monitored bed setting so tikin TI k
s YN is a drug that is approved for for
atrial fibrillation and it's an anti-
rythmic that can be proar rhythmic in
the same way as ibigan and actually has
more risk than iban the the the rates of
torsades are higher with tendence
approved and it's totally safe you just
do it you do it in a monitored cardiac
bed and so I think that we have to if
we're going to my suspicion is if we're
going to do a study in the US with IB
we're just going to need to do it in a
moderat cardiac bed with cardiologists
involved and I think if you do that
you're you're good right I think the the
trick is between now and and when you
know in theory one could see an approval
eventually from the FDA for this you're
going to have to think about well not
just can this place in wherever Mexico
wherever it is provide you know a good
pure form of Iain but what's the what's
kind of the wraparound risk reduction
there and I think that's what people
have to think about taking on that level
of risk it's not trivial risk though you
know I it's that's a real it's a real
risk I think the reason why the the
veterans that we studied were so
interested in going is because as you
point out there's a lot of risks from
not doing things too there's also a lot
of social proof in that Community now oh
yeah a friend will go down with their
friend to like sit in the same room and
it's a tight group right I mean it's a
super tight group and it's it's pretty
cool right and I think it the reason why
I did the trial ultimately was because I
my view was there's no way that all
these special these very high performing
special operators are all going down to
Mexico and taking this thing which is
not recreational at all and uh spending
a week down there dealing with this and
then they're not really getting benefit
they're getting some some sort of you
know pure placebo effect it just seemed
unlikely to me given how treatment
resistant how many things that these
folks had done how much time they' spent
in the VA hospital and all that good
stuff and so you know that's why we did
it and and what we found was enough of a
consistent finding and this reversal of
of disability such that the well I can't
tell you this works because I don't have
like that level of evidence on it that
the signal that this could work is
really high it's the highest of any any
kind of U brain acting drug I've you
know been involved in in looking at okay
let's talk about the the alcohol and the
caffeine yeah so mechanism of action I
mean you sort of mentioned the uh the
gdnf in the animal models right like the
direct kind of
injection uh how do you how do you think
about this and does it in any way tie
into what we're seeing with some of
these drugs that are I guess designed
for type 2 diabetics right like sem the
semaglutide and OIC like drugs but
they're having such an effect on various
types of Cravings that large boox
retailers are having to revise sort of
in a panic their sales projections and
inventory planning around like snack
foods and stuff I mean it's wild to see
like the societal Ripple effects Walmart
apparently has
uh sold less food yeah and I have
friends who have been obese effectively
their entire lives never had an exercise
habit and now they're doing pull-ups for
the first time right which is which is
again not an endorsement because I don't
understand and maybe nobody really quite
understands exactly how these things
work but I certainly don't so I'm not
yet there how do you think about this I
mean is are there any overlaps with
these are they completely different
mechanisms just presenting similarly
yeah it's a great question I mean
there's no evidence that there's like a
a direct overlap in mechanism just
because the kind of CNS kind of Psych
addictions um side of things people are
still in the like is this doing
something yeah it looks like it's doing
something there but not any deeper than
that I think we'll learn about that you
know on the o zimic drug side of things
and then you know iban's been relatively
you know underexplored from a basic
stence standpoint but my suspition is is
that it is probably similar enough and
and maybe some of the Sim you know the
same mechanisms are being enacted
because what you're finding is a similar
phenomenon across both instances we
thought these were were diabetes drugs
and there was a significant weight loss
observed and then we thought these were
weight loss drugs and then everybody's
quitting all their all their other
habits you know and you know Placebo
works by a phenomenon called
expectancy and as you can expect from
the term it's expecting something right
so you you're primed to think that this
thing is going to help for this reason
I'm always really clued in when you have
really obscure of Target like non-ex
expectancy phenomenon happening so in
the in our in our abigan trial as you
mentioned a minute ago we had like
basically everybody quit drinking coffee
for a period of time and like none of
them really went into it as most of us
don't like our coffee habit is maybe a
concern maybe it's you know it's you it
looks like coffee is like protective
against like Parkinson's and some other
things you know so it's kind of a mixed
bag about that but it's it's generally
the thing we're the least worried about
trying to deal with right as a as a
generality people are much more focused
on dealing with with being overweight or
focused on you know their alcohol use
problem or their in this case PTSD and
depression and TBI and all these other
things that folks were worried about and
so when we started seeing like
consistent reports of people stopping
their their caffeine intake it was
really a signal for me I was like you
know what that's really interesting I
mean there's a there's probably a bigger
systemic change that's happening in what
people will tell you phenomenologically
about this is it puts a pause in between
stimulus and response and I can't like
prove this this is just what everybody
seems to come back and say it it puts a
period of time between when you normally
have a trigger to do something and go do
it and it was a habitual action and
really kind of gets into this question
of like Free Will and all this stuff
that people think about right where
there's a moment where instead of making
the habitual action the person finds
himself in a purely unbiased Choice
phenomenon what people have opiate use
disorder would say in those
scenarios when they would relapse after
I is they'd say you know what I I just I
had something about it I didn't crave it
I just wanted to do it or something
wanted to remember or whatever but it
wasn't this habitual action right and
they go back and they do I again after
they you know gone back back into the
addiction and then they they had all the
negative consequences and they say you
know what and they got back to that
choice again and they're like no I don't
it's not worth it anymore I'm going to
go this way but they were able to pause
and make those decisions and it sounds
like from talking to the various U
veterans that have gone through our
study is that they they'd approach
things like coffee and they'd be like
you know i' do this but do I need to do
it which is really striking actually
it's not something that like people
typically tend to do right you get into
all these habitual actions and your your
life is just made up of a lot of yeah
habitual actions and they were able to
re-evaluate all those habitual actions
and then establish new patterns the drug
eventually is going to wear off you know
as all drugs eventually do and you
probably do lay down a level of
habituating again but if you could
During the period of time when your
brain seems to be pretty you know
plastic you know shift and lay down new
patterns that when the drug wears off
assumably you kind of lock into that new
set of patterns and I think that's
what's really interesting and and
probably a little bit different than the
oics in the sense that the OIC seem to
kind of take away from what folks will
say a lot of the like seeking or
rewarding aspects of things like food or
whatever it's just Cravings yeah
Cravings this seems to you know
introduce a level of choice what what
would be very interesting and so you
know kind of alluded to this earlier is
you know you take somebody who has a
pretty significant addiction like this
you give them an ibigan sort of drug and
you you think about how do you use
something like an O zimic to kind of
follow on with that right yeah where
you're able to kind of gate some of it
it's way out there and probably not
anything anybody's going to do anytime
soon yeah but it's an interesting idea
right of these are essentially habit
affecting drugs that we haven't had
tools to really use before which I think
is pretty cool yeah and folks who want
to dive deeper into this of reopening of
let's call it critical windows I mean
I'm borrowing that terminology from uh
Professor ghoul Dolan but pretty fun
stuff to dig into as well if you want
to sort of scientifically at least for
the time being reinforce what a lot of
experienced facilitators have been
saying for a long time which is like the
post period matters a lot uh if you're
going to have KN surgery make sure you
do your your
rehab all right let's let's to to a few
other questions one is coming back to
Iain specifically the two things that
have been of greatest interest to me
with respect to Iain are TBI right so if
someone has no addiction no PTSD the
only issue they have is some form of TBI
do you think there is a role for iig
again so we can placehold that there's
there's part part two to this question
which is I have heard reports and I
haven't gone into literature on this
side I don't know maybe this has been
explained somewhere but I've certainly
heard reports of opiate addicts who have
seemed to indicate that ibigan or iboga
opens a window after treatment during
which they do not seem to experience
much in terms of withdrawal symptoms and
I want to know what the hell is going on
there if there's if that seems to be
observed right so those are the two
questions somebody who just has TBI do
you think there might be a role for an
Ian or something like it compared to
other options and then the diminishing
or disappearance of for a period of time
physical withdrawal symptoms it's a
little tough with the cohort that we
studied because they were you know those
military TBI while I understand that the
PTSD diagnosis is um pretty ubiquitous
in the system it's probably true in a
fair amount of folks especially folks
who've been exposed to a lot of combat
related trauma uh in in earlier life
trauma and in our group it seemed to be
there in most participants so you know
so was depression and anxiety and so we
haven't studied a pure TBI group and so
the confound is without studying a pure
TBI group that somehow had maybe was a
competitor in martial arts you know or
something like that multiple concussions
or whatever yeah something like that
where they like intended to potentially
get hit in the head
um probably intended to hit other people
in the head well for sure but in
intended intended to go into the ring
knowing that that you were probably
going to get hit cuz the problem right
is a lot of these cases motor vehicle
accidents there's really high rates of
PT um PTSD because there's not an
expectation you're going to you're about
to get hit in the head right and so but
but there's probably a population you
could study that's pure traumatic brain
injury where like football players right
I mean a lot of reported depression who
knows there could be a lot of other
factors involved but yeah football
players another great example highly
correlated yeah yeah and those guys know
they're going to hit their head in the
game probably at some point and so that
population where it's more of a pure TBI
population you could ask that same
question that we asked in this more you
know mixed population which is does TBI
disability improve we saw a dramatic
Improvement in TBI disability at one
month mark less actually right after it
really took a while for it to work which
is if you had to guess right we're we're
two drinks in and I'm like noan just
give me your wild ass guess like me
mechanistically what's going on here
it's this Symphony right which is sounds
kind of like maybe even hokey or like a
little like Less Direct but I I just
think that there's something about
interacting somehow with multiple
different neurotransmitter systems at
the same time that must produce this I
mean the the maybe the gdnf bdnf alone
could could do this I'm not saying it
can't but but I suspect that it's a more
complex process and the problem is we
don't have great tools to evaluate that
but but sometimes nature is trumps our
human scientific abilities and I think
that that iban certainly is there in in
uh 2023 it's like the story of scurvy
right like we we
Associated eventually after like a bunch
of weird stuff we we eventually
Associated eating oranges with
Improvement and scurvy but it took us
another hundred years to synthesize
vitamin C that's I think what's so hard
about this scientifically and to get the
kind of scientific Community fully on
board with these ideas is that we're
likely going to figure out this works
before we have any idea on how it works
but it's very unique to IBN you can take
somebody who's going through fluid
opioid withdrawals and you can have them
not only have a cessation stopping of a
desire to go take more heroin or or
prescription opiates or whatever it is
but you can have them basically blunt or
completely attenuate the physical
withdrawal symptoms of withdrawing from
opiates right which is diarrhea like
headache sweating all the stuff that
people will go through when they're
going into opiate withdrawals and this
seems to really kind of like knock that
out it's likely again that because it's
interacting with the opioid receptors
it's it's interacting with with the
glutamate system but you know it is to
my knowledge you know none of the other
psychedelics can do that ketamine can't
really do that so this is a pretty
unique thing to ibigan that it can pull
this off and why I think it's such an
important drug to understand I mean I
would argue that because of how broad
Ian seems to work across now you know
most most of the major psychiatric
diagnoses with the absence of something
like schizophrenia But anxiety
depression PTSD you know this traumatic
brain injury you know multiple different
addiction types it's going to behoove
scientific Community to really kind of
break down why it does what it does over
the next couple of decades I think and
try to really kind of back engineer what
it is but yeah we have no idea outside
of the lab and more in the wild what are
what are some of the more interesting
things happening related to ibugan and
iBook I I believe there's something
happening in Kentucky yes I've been down
to Kentucky to testify in front of the
opiate abatement Commission of Kentucky
it was myself along with shreni Ral from
maai Deborah Mash who's a CEO of Dix was
at the University of Miami for a while
in Canal who who was at Miu and is kind
of an academic Private Practice A guy by
the name of Brian hubber which is he's a
very interesting guy he's an attorney by
training has worked in a bunch of
different domains Within Kentucky state
government and whatnot and he for one
reason or another has become completely
convinced that the money that ended up
being some of the lawsuit money for some
of the opiate overprescription that
happened particularly in Kentucky and
West Virginia but all over the country
should be utilized for novel
Therapeutics and not just for more of
the same sort of treatments that we have
available you know the conventional
treatments that are available for opius
disorder fall into the realm of what
think about is replacement therapy
you're replacing a higher risk opiate
with a lower risk opiate so that's
Suboxone and which contains
buprenorphine and methadone or opiate
blocking drugs like nxone there's a a
fairly High fail rate on those drugs
part of it is psychosocial you know we
put people in the right environment you
could probably drive up the rates of
that there's also a prescription issue
you used to have to have like a special
FDA license to prescribe it I I used to
have this thing and then recently that
was knocked out so everybody with a
medical license can prescribe Suboxone
and so there's a group of drugs that can
do some work on this but there's
certainly folks that we would think
about as treatment resistant opiate use
disorder patients and the the the
numbers I'm not going to get into
because there's you know they're debated
or whatever but whatever those numbers
are it's a it's a good chunk of folks
and they don't really have much uh to
offer and so people have thought about
lots of different options for for them
and one of the options is brain surgery
so in West Virg irginia a group of
neurosurgeons are actually doing full-on
you know so there's a there's a surgical
form of neuromodulation called deep
brain stimulation where you can actually
put an implanted device into the reward
system and also kind kind of similar to
to some of these wovi kind of drugs you
can drive down you know some of the
pleasure around this is more theoretical
at this point opiates as well as there's
some data out of you know a couple of
different studies with even like weight
loss for for stimulating in the reward
circuitry what's interesting is that
there's a a one in 100 risk of a of a
head bed from that um that treatment and
and about you know about a third of them
end up it ends up being a pretty
significant head bleed right yeah what's
what's really interesting is you you
have no one in West Virginia organizing
all these hearings about it's just
happening they're letting people do the
science and all that stuff and I don't
disagree with doing that by the way I
think it's it's a useful thing to
explore and it may be a solution for
this right and and this is as we
described earlier such a high-risk
phenomenon that a 1 in 300 risk is is
not 1 in 300 or 1 in 100 one and one
under risk of a DBS it can be a trivial
just Blood on the tip of the electrode
which is asymptomatic about a third of
those people are going to be you know in
a more comp have a real complication so
and then you got about 1 in 300 risk of
a torsades risk with Iain so next door
in in Kentucky similar odds yeah yeah
you got a similar odd concern you know
both of which can be kind of dealt with
in the hospital I'd argue that the Iain
risk is probably a little less actually
than the than the DBS risk if you just
kind of look at everything and and
they're having these significant
hearings there's a lot of opinions about
this and a lot of shocker right you know
I'm one of the few people that does all
this stuff so I can kind of like and you
just toose part of the reason why having
this conversation cuz you like you
bridge a bunch of interesting often
separate worlds so anyway yeah thanks
man yeah so down there and there were a
million questions about the cardiac risk
and about you know whether or not this
should be done and and particularly
should State funds be be funding this
and there are various opinions about
that my my opinion and the reason I was
willing to go down there and support the
effort is there are a subpopulation of
people and which Suboxone nxone and
methadone don't work right and and we we
need to spend some money on trying to
help those people quote unquote working
has different outcomes right if you're
talking about like substitution
therapies as as well right that's right
is living on yeah replacement on on
opiates you know if you're you're having
to do this your whole life I mean It's
Tricky you lose your prescription in a
flight to wherever and then now you're
you're like in a really bad place and so
this idea of instead of replacement or
substitution or whatever Interruption
which is what IBN is going to do and I
think at some level what DBS is going to
do too right it's going to interrupt
that system that circuit that's driving
the seeking behavior and be able to kind
of reorganize the brain such the person
approaches the problem in a different
way is a promise that I think everybody
wants to see I think the the interesting
part about this whole phenomenon down
there is you know from the folks that
are opposed to this is this view that
one the current treatments are fine or
whatever and then two that you know how
could it be that this you know extract
from a root in an African country
somehow be something that can do what
modern humans in Pharma can't do and it
goes back to what I think is a pretty
hubristic part of the human psyche which
is that I need to start the fire I need
to hammer the wheel I need to you know
the sort of not invented here kind of
thing yeah yeah right and and I think
the idea that somehow somehow this just
exists it it goes around the psyche uh
in a way that doesn't really work and we
saw this was with scurvy too right I've
spent a lot of time like studying scurvy
because I I'm very interested in this
human phenomenon there were people
called anti
fruiters I'm not kidding you it's a real
term wow and they were in the Royal
Societies in the 1750s and so we knew
from
1498 that folks that were going Around
the Horn of Africa and going to Asia
that way they'd plant fruit tree they'd
plant like citrus trees all the way
there so we were doing this and at some
point scurvy got worse and all that and
people said there's there's like
literally no
way that these fruits could be the
solution for this humans have to solve
this and actually the fruits are
probably what's making it worse ah so
James Lind ran the first clinical trial
in the history of humans on scurvy and
citrus fruit where he gave all these
like various weird concoctions like
poisons and uh like they gave s they
were trying to get people cyanide they
were trying to get people alcohol mixed
with acid this this is what they thought
yeah and and so he gave people he
randomized people on a ship with scurvy
to these various things in citrus fruit
and what happened was the citrus fruit
receiving people at the end of the week
were taking care of everybody else but
it took another hundred years and I
think I think this is this meta
phenomenon of people need to feel like
they made it in that culture within that
context that this is the latest and
greatest thing it needs to be kind of
like very proximal in time it needs to
be new you know it's got to be the new
thing to be the solution and I think
that's part of what's going on in
Kentucky from my view of it if you look
at West Virginia and you just look at
like the actual information of what's
going on you'd you'd probably be more
likely to to cause and I I don't think
that people should but question the
brain surgery thing if you really get
down to it over the Iain thing just on
the risk portfolio and having to have a
implanted device for the rest of your
life but nobody say there's like nothing
there and it's because we're making this
Western Society is making this really
Innovative new treatment that requires a
brain surgery and d and that's totally
cool from from their perspective and I
think that we've got to as a culture and
as a scientific Community really change
the way that we think about evaluating
you know tests and particularly
therapies and look at the inherent
scientific
complexity and not the temporal
proximity and the fact that we made it
or whatever you know and those sorts of
things that that I think drive people to
have these misconceptions and so so yeah
so KY is really interesting it's really
an argument about whether or not some of
this money should be earmarked and
whether whether or not it should be
studied and I think both of those things
are are a yes you know we should be it's
got It's the best candidate that we know
about the risks are mitigable and
similar to to DBS there so many facets
to this right like insurance
reimbursement scaling therapist
availability or I should say more
medical availability for like the dur of
stay that would be required with Ian
versus like there's so many facets to
all this in terms of say getting to
Patient 10,000 right whether it's this
this DBS implant surgery or ivag again
right there's just it's there's so many
levels of nuance but at the basic
science level and the further research
if I mean who am I to say but it's it
seems like the the cost and severity and
prevalence of the problem is such that
the answer is of course yes yeah yeah of
course it's yes I do want to ask you
about synthesis specifically really a DI
game because I'm always fascinated by
rate limiting steps and also unintended
consequences
of uh using different compounds that
occur in nature before we get there I
want to very selfishly throw in a wild
card question around uh irbs and funding
studies and getting ethical approvals
because I would love to see more studies
on extended fasts in humans but to my
know
those basically got taken off of the
table if I wanted to try to make the
case and fund some science related to
Extended fasts and humans any
suggestions I think everything's
studable-winter some sort of medical
psychiatric whatever it is condition
that you think that the benefit of doing
that significantly outweighs the risk I
think I can make that case then I think
you can do it it it really is just that
right it's it's this ethical and and I
think it's I agree with it right it's
this ethical justification that like
we're going to we're going to be able to
do more good by trying to do something
like this than to do to do harm I mean a
study that would never go through any
IRB is we're going to randomize people
to no motorcycle helmet or motorcycle
helmet and have them do laps around the
university you know like like the the
the we pretty much know the answer to
that that question and the benefit of
knowing knowing in a randomized control
trial way the benefit of the answer to
that question you know does not outweigh
the risk at the individual patient or
participant level of of participating in
a trial like that so that trial would
never get done right and so I think
that's the way that we that we have to
kind of look at it so if you've got a
reason your reason is you think that
that there's going to be some effect on
coronary artery disease or something
like that or yeah I think I think there
a couple a different approach I could
take just in case there's anyone
listening who who wants to do this and
there are extended people study fasting
in animals all the time right but it's
it's for for whatever set of reasons at
some point it seems to have been taken
off the table for human subjects I mean
there was research done I want to say
like the up until maybe the 40s and 50s
but then it kind of vanished and I'm
very interested in if I had to make the
case I would probably make some type of
case around what Chris Palmer at Harvard
and other people have called metabolic
Psychiatry so to look at this almost
like the accelerated TMS equivalent of a
ketogenic diet for certain psychiatric
conditions because you see some
incredible results and Chris has been on
the podcast say ketogenic diet as
applied to conditions like schizophrenia
for instance I mean remarkable
Transformations where people get off off
of half a dozen or dozen medications and
like you I am interested in
Practical Solutions and especially
things that are uncrowded from the
perspective of scientific support which
for a while has been psychedelics but
certainly accelerated TMS I'm agnostic
when it comes to the to to the tools I
think I'd probably make the metabolic
Psychiatry argument but the fact of the
matter is I also feel like it's been so
long since we applied modern tools
and tracking of biomarkers and so on
everything that we have at hand now to
human fasting that may not be the
argument that I would use but certainly
there is that okay yeah absolutely so
synthesis there's a great piece that
came out in National Geographic not too
long ago by journalist Nam uh Rachel
newer I think I'm getting the last name
right Nu We R she also has a great book
on MDMA and MDMA assisted Psychotherapy
the history and implications that
recently came out and Shea traveled to I
think it was gabun although I think
there is also I think you can also find
iboga in Cameroon if I'm not mistaken
and she went on the ground to look at
all the implications of global demand
for ibigan and iboga and it's it's very
very nuanced but it seems clear and I
wrote a piece a long time ago on my blog
which was a uh letter to users of
psychedelics like a plea for a more
ethical menu of options something like
that to just point out some of the dimin
fining
natural supplies for say peyote right
like almost certainly going to go
extinct use something else use Sedro
Cactus look at the look at the growth
Cycles just don't touch it unless you're
part of a culture that uh has this as an
integral part of of tradition and
healing as would be the case for say
people who are in the Native American
church and so on but ibigan can be can
be had in I guess a number of different
ways maybe you could speak to like the
the known option and then looking
forward what some of the most
interesting options are for whether it's
it's like extraction or or synthesis
there's kind of the straight extract out
of the iboga Tre as you're pointing out
and that's that one's probably a pretty
big ethical issue because what's
happening and and I think that National
Geographic article really reflect this
is that there's such a global demand
that it drives the prices up in the buti
the peoples that take I ioga in gaban
and and in surrounding countries no
longer can access it because the the
high cost which is the last thing that
you want to have happen right that's the
thing that you're that everybody I think
should be trying to avoid first what
else can you do right so another way to
do this is that there's a another Tree
in Ghana and other places in Africa that
has a voan gene which is a very similar
but not identical alkaloid to ibigan
it's actually not even a controlled
substance so vangen is not on the
controlled substances list it's not as
much of an issue cuz there's not really
a current medicinal usage of vangi or
you know utilization of that within
those cultures that have these trees
it's also more commercially cultivated
if I'm not mistaken right for maybe
fragrances or something I can't recall
the commercial use it's pretty
ubiquitous too I mean i' I've heard that
that it's not just in Africa it's in
some of Central and South America and so
you can extract the vangi and then you
can do this simple chemical uh step to
get it to ibigan do a Sy synthesis
pathway of of Iain from from denovo it's
like 26 plus steps or something like
that but this is like the last step
before it's IBN from voni and so it's
it's
really pretty straightforward to do that
but you're still talking about a
Botanical right you're still talking
about essentially growing a plant to
derive a chemical out of the plant so
the other way to think about it is
because you do a full chemical synthesis
and people have looked at that and tried
to do it it's very hard though because
ibigan has two chyro Center so it has
the potential for four stereo anomers
and that chemistry is complicated and so
full synthesis is a tricky process my
suspicion is that whether it be
biosynthesis or straight full synthesis
but there's got to be a way to to to
make this that avoids trees eventually I
think it's better for the environment
it's going to be more scalable um it's
going to be something that standard
Pharma is going to want to see happen um
to really be able to use it there's
still some time to get from A to B as
far as that goes so I think it's not a
done deal it's not completely figured
out yet this a bridging from that I mean
this is this is actually a completely
separate question but uh also raises
some sustainability ethical questions 5
Meo DMT so five methoxy DMT first of all
I would really implore people I'll link
to this in the show notes as well uh
read the blog post that I put together
so the 5o DMT I mean it it's it's
present in quite a few different plants
different nuts most people who have
heard it in the zeist know it within the
context of buo alvarus there are other
scientific names for this this toad
thisor desert Toad and that has turned
into a huge mess in terms of like cartel
harvesting and over harvesting uh from
these from these poor toads it can be
synthesized there are ways to synthesize
it Hamilton Morris has beat the drum
about this to his credit there is no
people are not going to like this but
there is no documented indigenous use of
the sor toad Ken Nelson you can look it
up in the ' 80s produced a pamphlet
after testing God knows how many things
brilliant amateur biochemist but
nonetheless it is interesting and
appealing on a whole number of levels a
lot of people are trying to
commercialize it because at least in
Earth time it is a short experience
right so that's going 10 to 20 minutes
10 to 15 minutes so from a business
model perspective I understand the
appeal much like I understand the appeal
of the newly branded psychop plasticin
right right psychedelics with the
content SL uh mind altering aspects as
removed as possible we might come back
to that but my question related to this
is is not so much on the production side
because people can read about that
separately and I think it's important
for people to read about it's more of
practical use following Iain
Administration I believe I've heard
people describe its use on what some
people call the gray day following
Administration could you speak to this
because I'm trying to discern for myself
how important or critical it is from a
therapeutic outcomes perspective versus
being a business differentiator does
that make sense like this is something
we kind of you know we put a nice set of
icing on top of the cake and that
includes this what can often be a
Sublime experience not always for people
it can be destabilizing for some folks
but in the form of 5mo DMT so what's
what's your take on this so we
specifically you know made sure that
folks weren't getting you know a second
kind of confounding drug on top of the
ibigan to figure out what the ibigan
effects were in isolation and as I
described earlier you know we had
extremely remarkable effects in the
absence of doing the 5 Meo I think what
people say about this the 5o at minimum
it just seems to take the edge off the
gray day which is a day that happens for
not everybody that takes iig game but a
fair percentage of people such that
there's a name for it where people for
some reason end up having kind of a bad
day in and around like Day 2 three where
they really have a hard time and then it
goes away the next day hard time meaning
depressive symptoms some people what is
heart okay yeah what makes it hard
anxiety yeah like anhedonia low low uh
motivation I think probably what's going
on is there was like a serious kind of
flooding of your your CNS with with a
whole host of effects from the drug and
then and the brains and kind of reacting
to that and then it seems to seems to
kind of rebound out on its own without
without the 5mo but it sounds like from
what I've heard the 5mo kind of bridges
people out of that so they don't have to
really have have to experience that that
feeling now the question would be does
it do something else beyond that that's
useful and we have no idea what we I
suppose what we could have done or maybe
what we could do in a sub quent study is
to just randomize people to getting no
5mo after or 5o and we can actually
answer that question does it does it
have an effect on the long term it's
hard because there's like a floor effect
of just like the you know the profound
improvements that we saw just from I so
you'd have to my guess is that the
statistics would tell you that you have
to do a pretty large sample to be able
to see something if it's there with 5
Meo just because of the floor you know
everybody's flooring out just with
ibigan when you say flooring out you're
just does that mean mean that the
amplitude of the effect is so great that
in terms of like seeing a a large
percentage improvement over the IB you
need to see something great or what do
you mean by flooring out yeah yeah yeah
so I mean essentially we're seeing
people drop down within that normal
range floring out on the on the
assessments on the assessments people
are going into the range of like a score
of 5 six something like that on various
scales this the PTSD scales the
depression scales you're in the normal
range and so you'd have to zero people
out with a 5 Meo Essen
or the other thing that it may do which
we have noide nobody knows probably is
whether or not it it makes some of these
folks who were and you'll see in the
paper there are a couple people that
relapsed at the month Mark maybe it
helps with durability on some people
that could do those things so I'm I'm
not saying that that it doesn't have a
benefit it's just it would be a hard
study to to deal with and I think from
like a purist I want to see this go
through the FDA and kind of do the FDA
things and see if we can get you know
the first drug kind of through the
process I don't want to say it's a
distraction from a US kind of scientific
regulatory strategy standpoint but it's
it's definitely something that would add
complexity I think at the level of
clinics that are doing this in
Mexico and they have free range to use
these substances I don't think it's on
the face of it like a terrible thing to
do I think it makes sense why they're
doing it do you really think that I just
I guess just to push on that a little
bit I'm like okay so people have a hard
day but it's known that this is a
phenomenon so they could prep people for
the possibility that they would
experience this hard day if they're not
somehow edging into dangerous territory
where they're likely to self harm I mean
5mo DMT I have some experience with it I
understand the appeal it's like satet
aanda Etc but it's not
risk-free I mean well you're you're
strapping yourself to a rocket yeah I
mean that is a big big gun right yeah
yeah which is not too malign anyone who
is is using this in a clinical setting
but it's not risk-free I mean I I have
friends who are very experienced
Psychonauts we're talking like 100 plus
reps with things like iasa who have been
pretty much even keill with with their
various experiments and been knocked
pretty sideways for non-trivial periods
of time by 5 a DMT maybe that's just the
sample set that I'm dealing with but I
totally agree with you mean medicine is
a discipline and a profession of risk
mitigation and risk benefit ratios and
everything and anybody that would
Proclaim themselves to be um you know
physician scientist that doesn't believe
that isn't seeing it as it is right
there's you know everything that I do is
some sort of risk mitigation exercise
where I'm looking at this thing has
these risks but this person has these
inherent risks and how do you how do you
kind of square all that I think it's to
your point it would totally make sense
if the person was in such a bad place in
the grade day that you were worried
about them I think there's a
justification there if you really is it
is it seems they do have some you know
General experience that this was helpful
to kind of getting folks out you know
the the reality is is that we're really
not going to know much of anything and a
lot of this is going to be in the realm
of anecdote until we do the trials in
the US and really you know thoroughly
document everything that happens with
this draw with ibigan with 5o which as
you know people are trying to you know
put through trials and Commercial that
and so I think I think there's a moment
where we'll be able to kind of you know
Rectify all of this and figure it out I
agree with you too that I think that
MDMA may be a substance that um
certainly not everybody could use but
like a decently broad populationbased
drug that that a fair amount of the
population that had PTSD could go after
I think that these substances are more
constrained to a smaller population
where the risk benefit is is right for
them
it's a tricky moment right I think we
know just enough to be dangerous in some
places and uh and we got to get through
this just enough to be dangerous moment
to the like we know how to not be
dangerous moment as a culture and do
that with with kind of the you know the
scientific process you were laying out
Psychiatry 1.0 2.0 3.0 mhm I'd love for
you to feel free to speculate right it's
going to be speculation but putting
aside like the I know it's hard to do
but like separating stuff in its
simplest form cleanest form through the
FDA Etc but like what might Psychiatry
4.0 look like that's right in the sense
that for instance something that's on my
mind and I'll keep it short is as I
understand it very at a very primitive
level the way that some of the
accelerated TMS protocols work from a
hardware perspective is you're kind of
hitting nodes at the exterior of the Hub
and kind of triangulating in a way to
hit what you're trying to hit but
perhaps you could use for instance in my
conversation with Nora vov of naida
she's talking about focused ultrasound
so maybe you use that to hit the deeper
structures directly you hit the nucleus
succumb or whatever it might be and then
related to that you if we're talking
about like Freud and so on focusing on
content right and then you've got this
sort of neurotransmitter Focus oh it's
it's the serotonin issue and then now
you have the
electrocutica it seems like these things
aren't necessarily wrong they're just at
least if we're looking at the content
the molecules incomplete right but if
but if you talk to a lot of these guys
who go through say the and gals but a
lot of these operators and men who go
through the Ian experience I mean they
will and maybe there's a visibility bias
because they can't see what the hell's
going on in their head but uh from a
chemical perspective but they can
remember the content but like a lot of
people would attribute the therapeutic
effects to much of the content right
this reconciliation and so on so what
might psychiatry 4.0 look like we have a
paper coming out soon where we're
actually trying to use neuros
stimulation to change trait
hypnotizability to make people more
suggestible transiently mhm and it's
probably an ability to zero in on
specific content and manipulate that
content through through circuit based
intervention you know and that's like a
pure speculation but like I give you
I'll give you an anecdotal kind of case
report there was a patient who got
similar sort of deep brain stimulation
approach that I was describing earlier
that they're looking at in West Virginia
for for addiction and that individual
received deep brain stimulation I think
in Europe I think for OCD and he was had
a normal musical taste right he listened
to whatever like all the range of of
standard artists and then he got his
deep brain stimulation and he became
obsessed with Johnny Cash like totally
sold all of his didn't see that coming
all right yeah yeah totally sold all of
his other um album and listen to Johnny
Cash and these and the batteries for
these brain stimulators will wear out
after time and you need a new one mhm
and it's decently common that if the
person's doing pretty well then they
they'll forget to come in and then all
of a sudden their battery's dead and
then they'll have a reemergence of
symptoms and so this gentleman did right
so I think it was his OCD and his OCD
got worse again and he fell out of favor
with Johnny Cash and threw away all of
his Johnny Cash albums and started
listening to whatever he was listening
to before went in and got a battery
change batter was put back in and he's
like for [__] sake I got to go back to
the shop and buy my Johnny Cash and
that's what he did yeah and and so we
have like just like we don't really
understand how iig game works we really
don't understand what happened there
right it was a very illustrative case
and I love like talking about that case
because it it gets into this area that I
think people are really worried about
right now about specific content
manipulation I don't think we can do
that we don't have the tools to do that
we have these like broad tools that
basically change the lens of the world
that you look through like I can change
your brain in such a way that you're
like for some people they're going to
see rosecolor glasses where they saw
blue before or whatever right it's like
I can give you a different set of
glasses to watch the movie but I can't
change the movie directly yeah they
can't change the movie directly my
suspicion is is that we're going to Edge
into a world where maybe we can change
the movie you know and that's where it
starts to get both very interesting and
very ethically complicated right and
that story about Johnny that doctor had
no intention of doing that cuz nobody
knows how to do that and maybe they
played Johnny Cash in the O maybe not
they didn't report that in the case
report but there's no clear sense of why
that happened either is this the first
song that was playing in the hospital
when he woke up and his brain the reward
system just kind of like attached to it
or whatever but it's one of these things
where we're going to get to a place of
sophistication and I think we're going
to be able to do that and what happens
in medicine as I I see it is we always
redefining what's illness this right and
so it used to be that high blood
pressure was like 150 over 100 or
something and it was 140 over 90 and
then it's 130 over 80 and now it's 125
over like 75 or whatever it is it's not
that the illness has changed it's our
definition of illness changed right my
suspicion is is that as we have enough
tools to be able to knock out these
major mental illnesses which were
effectively like instates mhm right at
the end of the day we let the system go
all the way to like this kind of
completely semi functional instate where
people have semi volition and they're
kind of stuck in these mindsets and
these behaviors if we can figure out
what that is and we have ways of
intervening sooner in that process my
and we have emerging tools that can you
know help you with this sort of content
targeting manipulation sort of thing
then I think you're going to be talking
about much more specific sort of
interventions that's like very sci-fi
though you know it's not something that
I think there's even like a hint of I
wouldn't even know how to tell you how
to do that now our like one shot on goal
is just to move around this brain trait
we do have a study with rag Aeron where
we're actually packaging ketamine into
nanop
particles infusing them into through
through an IV into the bloodstream and
then using ultrasound to kind of open
the nanoparticle ketamine and drop
ketamine just in the singulate in the
area that we were talking about earlier
in this case in pain patients cuz it's
it's easy to measure pain scales and
pain reactivity but but what I think
will be really interesting with that is
if you could take that same technology
and start to drop various psychedelics
into specific brain regions and you can
do a
behavior mapping exercise what's
necessary and sufficient to produce the
clinical Improvement what's necessary
and sufficient to produce the trip and I
think that's going to be way more
important than modifying the molecules
it's like a confound we're not really
answering the question of does tripless
Iain work cuz it's not Iain you know
it's just some some other thing right
but what what we really want to know is
does tripless iban work because we just
put it in the amydala or just into the
singulate or something like that and
that that in isolation isn't sufficient
to produce the trip but it's sufficient
to produce a therapeutic effect if we
can pull that off we're going to start
next year on that that's going to be
super cool because it's going to give us
the ability to have more of these
questions and you could even think about
it like if you had a long acting
anesthetic right where you had somebody
with pretty pronounced you know
psychosis schizophrenia symptoms coming
in and you able to shut down their
amydala for a couple of days with an
anesthetic just in the amydala nowhere
else they're totally awake they're still
with you but they fear
response or in the into the singulate
their kind of salience of the
environment response goes down because
you're able to kind of temporarily shut
it off but you're not having to give
like a whole body whole brain anesthetic
where you're putting somebody into a
medical coma or something you're just
you're just shutting down this one area
which you could potentially do through
neurom modulation and not with that and
not pharmaceutical right people have
tried to do that with deep brain
stimulation you can you can actually do
a jamming signal on certain areas and
shut it down too and that may be the
long-term solution right you're using
drugs like focal drugs to test it it's a
commitment it's not something you do an
emergency yeah right but but you could
in theory do this in the in the ER you
could take somebody that was acutely
psychotic you could put you know an
anesthetic that could kind of shut down
that system for transiently for a couple
of days and you could kind of get them
more on board with thinking about what
the long-term solution is when the fear
system isn't in place as much or all
total speculation it's it's not
something I have any direct data to
support but it's definitely interesting
let's push into a little bit more sci-fi
cuz it's it's fun and also a lot of
things that start in sci-fi end up in in
sigh right so stre right I mean you look
at Snow Crash by Neil Stevenson
and there are many many examples do you
think you could change handedness hand
dominance that one would be hard I mean
I think it's possible to do that at
childhood you know and we do do this in
stroke right we do this constraint
therapy sort of stuff where you actually
constrain the if you have a a big stroke
where you have one side of the brain you
have like a pretty devastating stroke
where people can't move move you know
their arm and all that good stuff or
they have minimal movement of their arm
and then they have an intact side that's
totally fine right you you actually
constrain the intact side and force the
person to use the the affected side to
drink water or to write or whatever and
when what you're trying to do is to kind
of reorganize the neural system in such
a way to where there's more cross
functional like attribution to that side
and so we have some evidence there's
ways to do that there's Corpus
callosotomy and various different like
pretty significant like say epilepsy
surgeries when they're really really
young like 1 years old 2 years old those
you know 3 years old whatever when you
look at those cases it can lose like a
pretty substantial part of their brain
from from whatever surgery they needed
to deal with their problem or if they
had a trauma or whatever they can
reorganize a system to be able to
reallocate resources to be able to do
bilateral sort of functions it's mostly
that the brain gets fixed mhm the
interesting thing about this idea of
critical periods and and whether or not
and and maybe what iban is doing and
whether or not you and make a more
plastic brain is this idea if you could
bring the brain to a more juvenile State
then you could probably neuro rehab it
better and that's going to be I think
one of the questions that will come out
of the data that we're going to present
is how far can this go right I mean we
saw like people go from mild moderate
TBI disability to to n on average which
is awesome and like never heard of but
if you keep pushing on that how far
could you go as something like that and
that's going to be a question that I
don't have an answer for but at least at
least there's like a signal there to
look that's kind of part of what I like
about like the general work that I try
to do is I I like to be relatively
disrupting and I like to be in spaces
where nobody else is working mhm I start
to not like it when everybody's doing it
so I'm like always now like where where
am I going I'm always looking for the
the thing or nobody's really in that
space studying it I always like it when
people think it's if people think it's
like really weird it's like a a positive
signal that I to do it kind of thing
certainly this area of using psychedelic
drugs to try to treat neuro deficits is
is not something that a whole lot of
people are really like looking into
right now so it's pretty curious and
hopefully we can ask some of those
questions uh one aspect of the
accelerated TMs in terms of I mean case
reports maybe too strong where it
anecdotal reports that I found
interesting is it seems like some folks
report increased visual Acuity or like
color
contrast and I found that very
interesting for a few reasons number one
is that is very commonly reported say if
you're on Lower doses or higher doses
but let's just say low to moderate doses
of certain psychedelics right it's sort
of like the the dial on your HD visual
perception is is set forward a few
clicks right y the flowers Sparkle just
a little bit more I mean you notice
details you would otherwise not noticed
and the reason I'm bringing this up I
mean that raises a lot of questions but
I'm bringing that up specifically
because
there are athletes who have talked about
the performance- enhancing benefits of
some types of psychedelic use and I
think Aaron Rogers would be one example
of this uh although I don't want to say
it's sort of in session use it's it's I
think more longer term implications
however there are people certainly I
know athletes who have used these things
to enhance their perceptual faculties
which then leads me to wonder and almost
assume that neuromodulation will be used
as a very hard to detect means of
performance enhancement in sports it's
hard for me to see how that would not be
the case with with people who are
willing to I think there was some type
of poll done at one point it's like
would you be willing to take a drug that
would guarantee you to get a gold medal
but it would reduce your lifespan by
like 5 or 10 years and the answer for
this thing that I'm it could be all made
up who knows the report supposedly
indicating that the the yes answer was
very very high percentage of respondents
right if they're looking at something
that has a lower risk
profile and is going to be impossible
for like the world anti-doping
Association to track yep why wouldn't
they try it you know absolutely we've
had a number of patients who've gone
through and they remitted really early
so they lost all their symptoms really
early in the week so like day one or two
and then by day three they've like
zeroed out and then like Thursday like
day 45 I remember this one guy who was
like I was driving by the the beach and
I saw the sun setting or whatever it was
I wanted to stop and and for whatever
reason just like sit on the beach and I
don't normally do that and then he
described how he was like completely
present in the present moment and able
to just be there and present and was
like watching the water for an hour and
he said I've never been able to do that
before but I used to do these
mindfulness courses that I couldn't
understand it felt a lot like that and I
went and found my book and it sounded
like I was having this kind of like
totally present mindful moment I've had
a ton of folks come back and tell me
this so if they remit really early and
we keep treating them we kind of treat
them through you know we've had folks
come through for this and you know folks
come through for for psychedelic
treatments it looks like day 345 out of
a psilocybin experiment where you've got
the person's no longer having any trip
they're not having any you know but
they're just calm and peaceful and kind
of pretty relaxed and present and it's
very similar to that right and so I
think that you're probably getting a
similar or the same state and I would
assume a state where a lot of um good
performance can happen from right
because you really are truly in this in
this moment not thinking about the
present or the future you know I've had
a lot of folks actually offer and at
some point we need to do this but offer
various like philanthropic gifts for me
to run trials on Athlete Performance I
knew it I knew it of course so I had
yeah one of our donors said to me I will
give you the money if you will take me
and all of my group of friends all my
post Finance guy triathlete friends
basically that yeah and and uh we cycle
every morning and and randomize us to
shammer active stimulation before we get
on the bikes and he's like the reason
why this is good is because we make the
same exact times and everybody knows
their times and d and can you can you
change this there's there's a little bit
of evidence for this it was a paper that
was published a couple years ago where
they took people and taught them to do
like Complex Motor tasks like hand tasks
where it's like tap digit one 35 135 135
and then intersperse it with 2 4 135 24
like that it's like a complex kind of
multistep and if you prime the motor
learning area before you do that you can
cut the speed of acquisition in half
compared to the people that had sham
that's non-trivial seems non-trivial
yeah and so it's it's it's interesting
right like there's some really early
like preliminary data to suggest that
you could potentially improve
performance with neur stem
the thing about it is if you really
could have something something that you
know people have been thinking about TMS
as a treatment for
insomnia you know others for acute
anxiety if you could come up with
something that could you kind of put the
breaks on a couple of different
symptomatologies maybe it's a TMS device
maybe it's another technology you can
make it something you could bring home
then you'd have the ability to have this
kind of full service sort of you know
process for dealing with things I think
trying to treat depression and isolation
or something like that you're never
going to be able to scale I think one
treatment alone but if we get to a place
where we can use this for a lot of
different functions and actually you
know this hypnotizability stuff drive
people up to be able to you know receive
information better or study better or
whatever do motor tasks better and then
turn it off and flip it on to like sleep
mode you know and you had a level of
more control over your brain than just
your own volition it's your volition
plus your valtion to do these things and
I think it's very interesting it's it's
also very sci-fi though I mean we we're
not anywhere close to knowing we can do
that yet not anywhere close fun food for
thought at the very least Nolan one more
time where can people find your lab
online so it's BSL stanford.edu brain
it's the Stanford brain stimulation lab
great and any other websites you'd like
to point people to I think that one's
that's the place to go that's home base
anything else you'd like to say before
we wind to a close any comments public
complaints it's been super fun I mean I
think you've definitely gotten yourself
quite up to to speed and kind of right
in the the center of a lot of the pulse
of this both on the neuros side and the
Psychedelic side yeah appreciate the the
kind of the knowledge coming in and your
your interests and the ability to to
have a conversation around these these
topics so well thank you for saying that
I I really have enjoyed delving into
this field you've been incredibly
helpful as as a resource and a sanity ch
check since I I get get all excited
about things and sometimes can can fly
off the rails but uh it's been so much
fun to engage with this hopefully soon
to be dramatically expanded sort of
field of experimentation especially
given the remission rates and the
durability I mean I've seen and the
reason I first began exploring this was
I saw a friend's family completely
transformed and the before and after was
just truly unbeliev one of the most
unbelievable Transformations I've ever
seen in my life it happened quickly I
think it was about day three mhm many
many failed interventions really
critical situation lots of self harm and
it was just like control Z undo and back
to the person they used to be and it's
been durable with I want to say let's
call them single day boosters maybe once
a quarter or once every 6 months and I
think it's now been durable I want to
say probably a year and a half which is
just phenomenal so I appreciate the work
you do I appreciate
the I appreciate you being The Last Man
Standing on the scientific Bachelorette
I suspect that'll happen again yeah
probably and thanks for taking the time
for the conversation man yeah thank you
look forward to watching what you do in
the future and for everybody listening
we will link to everything we discussed
in the show notes including Nolan's Lab
at Tim uplog podcast till next time be a
little bit Kinder than is necessary to
others and to yourself and thanks for
tuning in